This episode is brought to you by HelloFresh. Be honest, between meetings, workout classes, and the kids' clubs, who's got time to cook? That's where HelloFresh comes in. No matter how busy you get, HelloFresh makes it easy to get a home-cooked meal on the table. With flavor-packed recipes like crispy chicken parmigiana, you'll be filling your kitchen with the cozy aromas of a homemade meal in no time. Visit HelloFresh.ca and use code SPOTIFY for your exclusive offer. This episode is brought to you by Dyson On Track.
本集由 HelloFresh 赞助播出。说实话，在会议、健身课和孩子们的俱乐部之间，谁有时间做饭？这就是 HelloFresh 派上用场的时候了。无论你有多忙，HelloFresh 都能让你轻松在家吃上一顿热乎饭。通过香脆帕尔马鸡排这样风味十足的食谱，你很快就能让厨房充满家常菜的温暖香气。访问 HelloFresh.ca，并使用优惠码 SPOTIFY 即可享受您的专属优惠。本集由 Dyson On Track 赞助播出。
Dyson On Track headphones offer best-in-class noise cancellation and an enhanced sound range, making them perfect for enjoying music and podcasts. Get up to 55 hours of listening with active noise-cancelling-enabled, soft microfiber cushions engineered for comfort, and a range of colors and finishes. Dyson On Track. Headphones remastered. Buy from DysonCanada.ca. With ANC on, performance may vary based on environmental conditions and usage. Accessories sold separately. Merry almost Christmas, everyone. We are actually on our holiday break right now, but we're keeping the second drinks going! Yes, we are!
Dyson On Track 头戴式耳机提供同类最佳的主动降噪功能和增强的音域，使其非常适合欣赏音乐和播客。在开启主动降噪的情况下可享受长达 55 小时的聆听体验，柔软的超细纤维耳垫专为舒适度而设计，并提供多种颜色和饰面可供选择。Dyson On Track。重塑耳机。请在 DysonCanada.ca 购买。开启主动降噪时，性能可能会因环境条件和使用情况而异。配件单独出售。祝大家圣诞快乐。我们现在其实正在休假，但我们要继续“第二杯”！没错，我们要继续！
And today we are taking a big second drink of the Dundee's. The Dundee's, you know, was a big episode for us. It kicked off season two of The Office, and it was the first episode of The Office that aired after Steve Carell hit it big in The 40-Year-Old Virgin over the summer. It changed everything. Yes. In fact, this was supposed to be our third episode of the season, but we switched it
而今天我们要痛饮第二杯《邓迪奖》。你知道的，《邓迪奖》对我们来说是一个非常重要的剧集。它拉开了《办公室》第二季的序幕，也是《办公室》在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔凭借暑期大片《四十岁的老处男》大红大紫之后播出的第一集。它改变了一切。没错。事实上，这本应是我们本季的第三集，但我们把它换成了……
to being the first after the success of The 40-Year-Old Virgin. They thought this is the episode people who loved 40-Year-Old Virgin might like to see. They were smart. They were. And in this breakdown, we told our stories of going to the 40-year-old Virgin premiere, so you can enjoy those again. But to kick things off for second drink, since I know everyone has been on pins and needles. It's a cat calendar update.
在《四十岁的老处男》获得成功后将其改为第一集。他们认为，喜欢《四十岁的老处男》的观众可能会想看这一集。他们很聪明。确实很聪明。在这集幕后解析中，我们讲述了去参加《四十岁的老处男》首映式的经历，这样你们就可以再次重温了。但为了给第二杯拉开序幕，我知道大家一直都如坐针毡。这是一个猫咪日历的更新。
Are you ready? I don't know. Am I? There is no cat calendar at reception. It's gone. Whoa. However, the all-hands meeting poster is still there. We are all still meeting on Saturday.
准备好了吗？我不知道。我准备好了吗？前台已经没有猫咪日历了。它不见了。哇。不过，全体员工会议的海报还在。我们所有人仍然在周六开会。
I like to think that Angela Martin took down that cat calendar. Did she think I wasn't worthy? You weren't worthy. Pam didn't love cats enough. She didn't have cats, she took it down. It was a gift from Angela Martin that Angela Martin took back.
我倾向于认为安吉拉·马丁把那个猫咪日历拿走了。她是觉得我不配吗？你确实不配。帕姆不够爱猫。她没有养猫，她就把日历拿走了。那是安吉拉·马丁送的礼物，后来又被安吉拉·马丁拿回去了。
Well, Jenna, in our breakdown of the Dundies, we also discuss the moment when Pam kisses Jim. We got a fan question asking if we thought it was their first kiss or if that was actually during casino night. We disagree, we have talked about this quite a bit. I have said it was their first kiss or if that was actually during casino night. We disagree, we have talked about this quite a bit. I have said it was their first kiss. I said that it was not.
詹娜，在我们的《邓迪奖》解析中，我们还讨论了帕姆亲吻吉姆的那个时刻。我们收到了粉丝提问，问我们觉得那是他们的初吻，还是其实是在赌场之夜发生的。我们有分歧，我们已经讨论过好几次了。我说那是他们的初吻。我说不是。
Well, I have found something to share about that kiss. I know you've been real excited. I have. To hit me with this. I have, you know, I don't know if it really clears anything up, but it just gives a little bit more insight. Well, what I think you mean is that it's getting more evidence to prove your opinion. No, no, you hear it and you tell me.
好吧，我找到了一些关于那个吻的分享内容。我知道你一直很激动。我是挺激动的。想用这个来反驳我。我确实，你知道的，我不知道这是否真的能澄清什么，但它只是提供了更多的见解。我想你的意思是，它收集了更多证据来证明你的观点。不，不，你听了就知道了。
Okay. I think maybe all it does is bomb detect of this, which is like, well, we're back where we started. Well, let's see. So I went back and I read the shooting draft. We did not share this the first time we watched. Here's what it said in the stage direction. Are you ready? Right after Pam says, but mostly I want to thank God.
好吧。我想也许它唯一做的就是进行炸弹探测，意思是，好吧，我们又回到了原点。好吧，我们来看看。于是我回去读了拍摄剧本。我们第一次看的时候没有分享这个。舞台说明里是这样写的。准备好了吗？就在帕姆说“但最主要是我想感谢上帝”之后。
She says, I feel God in this Chili's, don't you? And the stage direction says, Jim looks at Pam with admiration. Dwight turns on the wrap it up music. Pam grabs Michael and kisses him, leaving him speechless. Dwight hits a button on the Casio and we hear the, oh yeah, cue. Pam skips off the stage and back to her seat. As Jim pulls the seat out for the Dundee winner,
她说：“我觉得这个奇利餐厅里充满了神圣，你不觉得吗？”而舞台说明写道：吉姆带着赞赏的目光看着帕姆。德怀特打开了结束音乐。帕姆抓过迈克尔并亲吻了他，让他说不出话来。德怀特按下卡西欧键盘上的一个按钮，我们听到了“哦，耶”的音效。帕姆一蹦一跳地离开舞台，回到座位上。当吉姆为邓迪奖得主拉开座位时，
Pam impulsively grabs him and kisses him before sitting down. Jim sits down too. She has blown past the little kiss, but he is still blushing and very aware of it." Oh my gosh! That is not how I remember it. That is in the shooting draft. And now when you watch the episode, Pam kisses Michael on the cheek, still leaves him speechless, but it says Pam impulsively grabs Jim and kisses him. So I'm just saying. Okay. Okay.
帕姆冲动地抓住他，在坐下之前吻了他。吉姆也坐下了。她已经忽略了那个小小的吻，但他仍然在脸红，而且对此非常清楚。”哦，天哪！这跟我的记忆完全不一样。这就是拍摄剧本里写的。现在当你观看这一集时，帕姆亲吻了迈克尔的脸颊，依然让他说不出话来，但剧本上写的是“帕姆冲动地抓住吉姆并亲吻了他”。我只是这么说。好吧。好吧。
I know we can still debate it, but I feel like that does support my argument. All right. Well, I might stand corrected. Oh, you're I might stand corrected. Ooh! You're starting to sway me, I have to say. Well, in this episode, I very confidently share that the person at the end of this episode who plays the Chili's manager
我知道我们还可以争论，但我觉得这确实支持了我的观点。好吧，也许我得收回前言。哦，你……我可能得收回前言。噢！你开始说服我了，我必须承认。在这集中，我非常自信地分享说，本集结尾扮演奇利餐厅经理、
that bans Pam from coming back to Chili's, I say that this person was a real Chili's manager. This is what we were always told. Yeah, that's what everyone told us. That's sort of the lore that we were like, oh my goodness, they had a real Chili's person. Yes, that's what Greg believed. Well, guess what, everyone?
禁止帕姆再次进入奇利餐厅的那个人，我当时说这个人是真正的奇利餐厅经理。这就是我们一直被告知的。对，每个人都这么告诉我们的。这就是那种都市传说，让我们觉得，“哦，天哪，他们找了一个真正的奇利餐厅的人。”是的，格雷格就是这么相信的。好吧，大家猜怎么着？
He is not a real Chili's manager. He is an actor. His name is Christopher T. Jones. And Christopher, please accept our sincerest apologies. Oh my goodness, Christopher. We had no idea. I was reading Andy Green's book about the office and Christopher is interviewed and here is what he said, quote, I was hired by the fantastic Alison Jones to work on the 40-year-old virgin
他不是真正的奇利餐厅经理。他是一名演员。他的名字叫克里斯托弗·T·琼斯。克里斯托弗，请接受我们最诚挚的歉意。哦，天哪，克里斯托弗。我们完全不知道。我当时在读安迪·格林关于《办公室》的书，书中采访了克里斯托弗，他是这么说的，引述：“我被出色的艾莉森·琼斯雇佣，去和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起拍摄《四十岁的老处男》，在里面扮演一个警察。
with Steve Carell as a cop. The scene I did was cut, but it made the deleted scenes on the DVD. I guess I did well enough because they brought me in to audition for the office. He went on to say, I think at least some of the extras were Chili's employees. And the reason I say that is because almost everyone assumed that I was actually a Chili's manager. So maybe that's where the mix-up happened.
我拍的那个场景被剪掉了，但它被收录在 DVD 的删减片段里。我想我表现得还不错，因为他们后来叫我去为《办公室》试镜。”他接着说：“我想至少有一些临时演员是奇利餐厅的员工。我这么说是因为几乎所有人都以为我真的是奇利餐厅的经理。所以也许这就是误会的来源。”
Yes. Because we did. I have such a memory of having Chili's people on set to make sure we got the whole Chili's of it right. Yes. And we talk about this in our breakdown. It was a surprise to the chilies folks that Pam was going to get drunk and Pam is supposed to vomit. And they were on set and they were like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
是的。因为我们确实这么认为了。我对现场有奇利餐厅员工这件事记忆犹新，他们确保我们把奇利餐厅的精髓完美呈现。是的。我们在解析中也谈到了这一点。奇利餐厅的工作人员很惊讶帕姆会喝醉，而且剧本里帕姆要呕吐。他们当时在现场，然后他们说：“不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, she can fall off a stool but she can't throw up. And we didn't realize she was going to be over-served and you need to add this talking head. Like all of that kind of happened on the set. So there were really Chili's people there and they were in the background of some scenes. Well poor Christopher said that he has been on Twitter trying to debunk this.
她可以从凳子上摔下来，但她不能吐。我们当时没意识到她会喝过量，而且你需要加上这个采访镜头。”诸如此类的事情基本上都是在片场发生的。所以现场确实有奇利餐厅的人，他们出现在一些场景的背景中。好吧，可怜的克里斯托弗说他一直在推特上试图澄清这个传言。
Awww. Fact. And he said people don't believe him. They're like no, you are a Chili's manager. And he has to be like, I promise you, I am not. And he said, I guess I should take it as a compliment toward my acting. But Christopher, since I didn't do it in this episode, I would like to give you a proper guest star breakdown. According to his IMDb bio, Christopher has been a working actor in Los Angeles since 2002.
噢。事实。他说人们不相信他。他们会说：“不，你就是奇利餐厅的经理。”而他不得不说：“我向你们保证，我真的不是。”他说：“我想我应该把这当作对我演技的赞美。”但是克里斯托弗，既然我没有在这一集中做到这一点，我希望能给你一个恰当的客串明星解析。根据他的 IMDb 简历，克里斯托弗自 2002 年以来一直是一名活跃在洛杉矶的演员。
He has appeared on numerous TV programs like Everybody Loves Raymond, Arrested Development, Joey, Two and a Half Men, ER, NCIS, Superstore, to just name a few, and he was most recently in the movie Barbie. Well, Christopher, I really hope this clears things up for you. You know, we're gonna put the word out in our office family community that you were not a Chili's employee, that you are in fact an actor playing a role that you did very well cuz we all believed you were a Chili's employee. Yes.
他出演过无数电视节目，比如《人人都爱雷蒙德》、《发展受阻》、《乔伊》、《好汉两个半》、《急诊室的故事》、《海军罪案调查处》、《超级商店》，等等，举不胜举，他最近还出演了电影《芭比》。好吧，克里斯托弗，我真心希望这能为你澄清一切。你知道的，我们会在我们的办公室大家庭社区里广而告之，你并不是奇利餐厅的员工，你实际上是一位扮演角色的演员，而且你演得非常好，因为我们所有人都相信你就是奇利餐厅的员工。是的。
And we just wish you all the best. Well, we have a few more things to cover in this second drinks tidbit section. Jenna, after this episode aired, a lot of people wondered, what did Pam write on the bathroom wall? Do you know? It was never scripted. And I was never told.
我们祝你一切都好。好吧，我们在这个“第二杯”花絮环节中还有几件事要讲。詹娜，在这集播出后，很多人都在想：帕姆在浴室墙上写了什么？你知道吗？剧本里从来没有写过。而且我也从来没有被告知过。
It was never written. It's for your imagination. It's kind of like the teapot letter. Fill in the blank. You decide what Pam wrote on the bathroom wall. Something else I didn't share in this original breakdown, you know at the end of the episode when Pam runs up to the camera and I shout, best Dundee's ever! Yeah, yeah.
从来没有写下来过。留给你们去想象。这有点像茶壶信。请填空。由你决定帕姆在浴室墙上写了什么。还有一件事我没有在最初的解析中分享过，你知道在剧集结尾，当帕姆跑到镜头前，我大喊：“史上最棒的邓迪奖！”时，对，对。
That was not in the script. Oh, a little improv. It was scripted that I'm just leaving and I'm kind of drunkenly hugging and kissing everybody as I leave. I even had a line where I was supposed to be like, Toby, you didn't get a Dundee here, you can have mine. And he's like, I don't really want it, Pam. But on the day, I think it was Greg that had the idea that I should run up and like shout at the camera. Then the other stuff was kind of played as B-roll. Those are the things I love.
那不在剧本里。哦，一点即兴发挥。剧本里写的是我直接离开，在我离开时，我有点醉醺醺地拥抱和亲吻每个人。我甚至有一句台词，我本该说：“托比，你这里没拿到邓迪奖，你可以拿我的。”然后他说：“我其实不想要它，帕姆。”但在拍摄当天，我想是格雷格提出了这个主意，让我跑过去对着镜头大喊。然后其他东西基本上都是作为B卷（花絮镜头）拍摄的。这些就是我最喜欢的部分。
They are the little moments we found while we were making it all together, that creative collaboration we always talk about. Well, there you have it. We hope you enjoy listening to this breakdown of the Dundies. Well, we are off this week. We wish you all a very happy holiday.
它们是我们在一起制作的过程中发现的小小时刻，也就是我们经常谈论的那种创意合作。好吧，就是这样。希望你们喜欢听这个《邓迪奖》的解析。好吧，我们这周休息。祝大家假期快乐。
And we will be back for second drink next week. We hope you have a nice one. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch Podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scenes
我们下周将回归“第二杯”节目。希望你们过得愉快。我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供独家幕后故事。
stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello everyone. Hi there. Guys, thank you so much for your support of our podcast and watching with us and listening with us. It means so much and we are loving all of your comments too. It has been so fun. I have loved going through the comments and going through the questions and the mailbox. All right, today we are moving into season two. Wow!
这些故事只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。你们好呀。伙计们，非常感谢你们对我们播客的支持，和我们一起观看，一起收听。这意义重大，我们也超级喜欢你们所有的评论。真的太有趣了。我非常喜欢浏览评论、翻阅问题和收件箱。好吧，今天我们将进入第二季。哇！
Season two, episode one, The Dundies, written by Mindy Kaling, directed by Greg Daniels. Yes, and you guys out there listening, we really wanted to do a live podcast of this at Achilles. But as it turns out, a lot of stuff is involved in doing that, and we just didn't get it together in time. But we do plan on doing some live podcasts. Yes, and maybe we'll go to Achilles.
第二季第一集，《邓迪奖》，由敏迪·卡aling编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。是的，听众朋友们，我们真的很想在奇利餐厅做一期现场播客。但事实证明，这涉及很多事情，我们没能及时把它凑齐。不过我们确实计划做一些现场播客。是的，也许我们会去奇利餐厅。
We have to make that happen. We have to make it happen. For sure. You're allowed back in now. I am. They lifted the band officially happen. We have to make it happen. For sure. You're allowed back in now. I am. They lifted the ban officially. They did.
我们一定要让它成真。我们必须让它成真。肯定的。你现在被允许进去了。我是。他们正式解除了禁令。他们确实解除了。
Like a year and a half ago. So I can now go to Achilles. So we have to make that happen. Yeah. There is so much to talk about with this episode. I have so many notes and I'm looking at my notes and I realized the one thing I don't have is a summary written down. What is wrong with you?
大概是一年半前。所以我现在可以去奇利餐厅了。所以我们一定要让它成真。对啊。关于这一集有太多可聊的了。我有好多的笔记，我看着我的笔记，然后我意识到我唯一没有写下的东西就是剧情摘要。你脑子里在想什么呢？
Can you believe it? I was so excited to get into the episode that I failed to write a summary, so here we go. I'm going to wing it. In this episode, manager Michael Scott gives out awards to his employees called the Dundies during a very awkward show at a Chili's. How'd I do? Mm-hmm. You did pretty great.
真不敢相信吧？我太兴奋了，急于进入这集节目，结果忘了写摘要，所以就这样吧。我要即兴发挥了。在这一集中，经理迈克尔·斯科特在一个奇利餐厅极其尴尬的颁奖典礼上，给他的员工颁发了被称为“邓迪奖”的奖项。我表现得怎么样？嗯哼。你表现得挺棒的。
He thinks he's like, you know, an amazing stand-up comedian, performer. I did see that a Dundie, I saw a description online of what a Dundee is. Okay. So if you look up Dundee, it says, a Dundee is an award bestowed annually by Dunder Mifflin Scranton, regional manager Michael Scott, in order to maintain morale, everybody gets a Dundee. Where did you read that? I did it, there's a thing called Dunderpedia. Oh, well, let's start with this fast fact. Okay. It's also a fan question. Aaron asked,
他觉得自己就像是个，你知道的，了不起的单口喜剧演员、表演者。我确实看到过关于邓迪奖的描述，我在网上看到过对什么是邓迪奖的解释。好吧。如果你查一下邓迪奖，上面写着：邓迪奖是邓德·米夫林斯克兰顿分公司区域经理迈克尔·斯科特为了维持士气而每年颁发的奖项，每个人都能得一个邓迪奖。你在哪儿看到的？我看了，有个叫邓德百科全书的东西。哦，好吧，让我们从这个趣味冷知识开始吧。好吧。这也是一个粉丝提问。阿伦问，
where did the idea for the Dundies come from? I don't know. The Dundies were based on an awards presentation that Greg Daniels did for his real-life employees on King of the Hill. Oh, my gosh. He was the Michael Scott of King of the Hill. Greg! He gave them out in a ceremony, and they were called the Swampies.
邓迪奖的创意是从哪儿来的？我不知道。邓迪奖是基于格雷格·丹尼尔斯为他在现实生活中的《山丘之王》员工们举办的一场颁奖典礼。哦，天哪。他简直就是《山丘之王》里的迈克尔·斯科特。格雷格！他在一个颁奖仪式上把奖发给大家，那些奖被称为“沼泽奖”。
Oh my Lord. And he gave out the same businessman statues that Michael gives out. He went into a trophy shop and he saw those statues and it inspired him to do an award show for his employees and then now it graduated into an idea for the office. I actually can really see Greg doing that. I can see him going and buying them and thinking it would boost everyone's spirits. Yes, it was a morale booster. Aww, Greg.
哦，天哪。而且他发的是和迈克尔发的一样的商人雕像。他走进一家奖杯店，看到了那些雕像，这启发他为他的员工举办一场颁奖典礼，然后这个想法现在升级成了《办公室》的一个点子。我其实真的能想象出格雷格做这件事的样子。我能想象他去买下那些奖杯，并认为这能振奋大家的精神。是的，这是一个士气振奋剂。噢，格雷格。
This leads me into fast fact number two. The Dundies was the story that Greg wanted to use as the season one episode one pilot. Instead of? Instead of the pilot. Yes. This was his idea for how to kick off the American version of The Office, but the network said they preferred we do an adaptation of the British pilot.
这让我想到了冷知识之二。邓迪奖其实是格雷格原本想用作第一季第一集试播集的故事情节。代替了什么？代替了试播集。是的。这就是他对如何开启美国版《办公室》的想法，但电视台说他们更倾向于让我们对英国版的试播集进行改编。
Wow. And Greg was very, very disappointed. But if you notice, and Angela maybe you did notice, there has been a Dundee on Michael's desk from the very beginning. It's in our opening credits. And Michael Scott, all through season one, had a Dundee. It's in the opening credits, but is it on his desk in the episode?
哇。格雷格当时非常非常失望。但如果你注意到的话——安吉拉，也许你注意到了——从一开始，迈克尔的桌子上就一直摆着一个邓迪奖。它出现在我们的片头字幕里。迈克尔·斯科特在整个第一季里都有一个邓迪奖。它在片头字幕里，但它在这一集里真的摆在他的桌子上吗？
Oh, well, now that I don't know. See, because I don't think it's on his actual desk, but I think it's in the credits. It's in the credits. Yes. But I do think that even that little bit is that way where Greg had something in his head. Right. He had this idea of these Dundee Awards looming for all this time.
哦，好吧，这个我就不知道了。你看，因为我不觉得它摆在他的真桌子上，但我认为它在片头里。它在片头里。是的。但我确实觉得，哪怕是这小小的一点细节，也体现了格雷格脑海中的某种构思。对。他心里一直盘算着这些邓迪奖。
And finally, when we got picked up, he was able to do something with it. Well, thank goodness we got a second season. That would really have been a bummer. Or else that little shot in the opening credits would have remained a mystery. What is the little man on his desk? What's the little man with the briefcase? What is it? Are we ready for fast fact number three?
最后，当我们获得预订时，他终于能够把这个想法付诸实践了。好吧，真庆幸我们拿到了第二季。那真的会让人很扫兴。否则片头字幕里的那个小镜头就会永远是一个谜了。他桌上的那个小人是什么？那个拿着公文包的小人是什么？那是什么？我们准备好迎接冷知识之三了吗？
We're moving more quickly than I thought we were. Well, let me just tell you, I'm just letting you go, lady. Jenna, I wish you guys could see her. She came in what looks like a mechanics outfit. Yeah, it's my green jumpsuit. Her green jumpsuit. But I also have a hat on. A hat on.
我们进展得比我想象的要快。好吧，我只能说，我正由着你发挥呢，女士。詹娜，我真希望你们能看到她。她穿得看起来像是一套机修工的衣服。对，这是我的绿色连体裤。她的绿色连体裤。但我还戴着一顶帽子。戴着一顶帽子。
It's like she came to play. Either that or pilot an airplane. But you are ready. Do you need anything assembled? Because I. It's like she came to play. Either that or pilot an airplane. But you are ready. Do you need anything assembled? Because I think I look like I could assemble something. Maybe. Okay, go, go, go. All right. Fast fact number three. The second season of The Office was originally only six episodes long. We only got picked up for six episodes. I know. We were so excited to get six. But after that, we're like, well, I guess that's it. That might be all. But they started airing. And then they ordered three more,
搞得她像是来大干一场的。要么就是去开飞机的。但你已经准备好了。你需要组装什么东西吗？因为我……搞得她像是来大干一场的。要么就是去开飞机的。但你已经准备好了。你需要组装什么东西吗？因为我觉得我看起来很擅长组装东西。也许吧。好吧，说吧，说吧，说吧。好吧。冷知识之三。《办公室》的第二季原本只有六集。我们只获得了六集的预订。我知道。我们当时能拿到六集就已经很兴奋了。但在那之后，我们想，好吧，我想这就是全部了。可能就这么多了。但它们开始播出了。然后他们又预订了三集，
then they ordered four more. Right. Then I think they ordered the rest of the whole season and we ended up with a usual amount of time. Yeah, but in the beginning we're like, well, we got six, well, that's that. Oh no, we got three more. Oh, we got, it kind of gave you that sense of like,
然后又预订了四集。对。然后我想他们预订了整季剩下的部分，我们最终得到了通常集数的播出时长。对，但在刚开始时，我们想，好吧，我们拿到了六集，好吧，那就这样了。哦，不，我们又多了三集。哦，我们又……它会给你一种感觉，就是，
well, we might as well go for it because we don't know if we're going to have this job. And this episode of the Dundee's was actually the third episode that we shot when we came back and it was the first episode that we ever shot away from our office set. This is the first time we went on a completely different location. It was really, really cool. And we shot this the week after Steve Carell's movie, The 40-Year-Old Virgin, hit theaters. Yes.
好吧，我们不妨放手一搏，因为我们不知道自己还能不能保住这份工作。而《邓迪奖》这一集，其实是我们回归后拍摄的第三集，也是我们第一次在办公室片场之外拍摄。这是我们第一次去到完全不同的外景地。真的非常非常酷。我们拍摄这一周正好赶上史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的电影《四十岁的老处男》上映。是的。
It was the number one movie at the box office. We were so excited for him. And Steve being the sweetheart that he has invited the whole entire cast to the premiere. Yeah. And we all went. We got dressed up. And that was like one of the first fancy movie anything
它是票房排名第一的电影。我们为他感到无比兴奋。史蒂夫是个大好人，他邀请了整个剧组去参加首映式。对。我们都去了。我们盛装出席。那是我去过的第一个那么高档的电影派对。
parties I've ever been to. I have a crazy story about that Angela. What? Well, we had been shooting all day and then the premiere was that night. Yeah. And we got dressed on set and the hair and makeup people did our hair and makeup and we carpooled and we went to this premiere. And when we got there, I was wearing this dress.
关于那件事我有一个疯狂的故事，安吉拉。什么？好吧，我们一整天都在拍摄，然后首映式就是那天晚上。对。我们在片场换好衣服，发型和化妆师给我们弄好了头发和妆容，我们拼车去了首映式。当我们到达那里时，我穿着这条裙子。
It's very hard to explain. Maybe we can find a photo of it and put it on our website. It was sort of like a lacy mermaid thing. It was like green and blue. I don't even remember where I got it or how I got it. It was my first big movie premiere. I didn't know what you were supposed to wear or how you were supposed to dress. It was a silky dress and then over it was a lace part. So the silk part was like the slip and then the lace part went over. Yes, a silk slip. Thank you, Angela. And it was blue and green, sort of mermaidy colors, I guess. And it had this really big ribbon around the hips. What is happening with this dress?
很难解释。也许我们可以找到一张照片把它发到我们的网站上。它有点像那种蕾丝美人鱼款式的裙子。它是绿蓝色的。我甚至不记得我是从哪儿买的，或者我是怎么弄到它的。那是我的第一场大型电影首映式。我根本不知道你该穿什么，或者你应该怎么打扮。那是条丝绸裙子，外面罩着一层蕾丝。所以丝绸部分就像衬裙，然后蕾丝部分罩在外面。是的，丝绸衬裙。谢谢你，安吉拉。它是蓝绿色的，大概是美人鱼的颜色吧。臀部周围还有一条很大的缎带。这条裙子到底是怎么回事？
And then it had the ribbon tassels were hanging down in the front. So when we got to the premiere, I had to pee so badly. So before we walked the red carpet, I ran into the bathroom and I peed very quickly. Did you pee on the ribbon? I did not pee on the ribbon. No, that would have been awful. That's where I thought the story was going. No, the ribbon did not dip in the toilet. Okay. But you know, that happens. Yeah, I said that because I feel like it's happened to me. Okay. I did not pee on the ribbon, but I was rushing and I came back out
然后缎带的流苏垂在前面。所以当我们到达首映式现场时，我急着想上厕所。所以在我们走红毯之前，我跑进洗手间，飞快地尿了个尿。你尿到缎带上了吗？我没有尿到缎带上。没有，那可就太糟了。我还以为故事要往那个方向发展呢。没有，缎带没有泡进马桶里。好吧。但你知道的，这种事常有。对，我这么说是因为我觉得这种事在我身上发生过。好吧。我没有尿到缎带上，但我当时很匆忙，我出来之后，
and I went to the red carpet. I took my pictures, I posed, I did the pictures, whirlwind, hoped I did it right, went inside. When I got inside, I realized that I had tucked the slip into my underwear. No! Was your butt showing in the lace in the photos? No, my butt was not showing. Thankfully, that ribbon was strategically poised to cover my lady bits. Oh Jenna. Oh my god. Because it was just lace on the bottom because I had tucked the slip into my underwear but it gets worse.
就上了红毯。我拍了照，摆好姿势，拍了照，一阵旋风，希望自己没摆错，然后就进去了。等我进去之后，我才意识到我把衬裙塞进内衣里了。不会吧！拍照的时候你的屁股透过蕾丝露出来了吗？没有，我的屁股没露出来。谢天谢地，那条缎带刚好巧妙地遮住了我的女性私密部位。哦，詹娜。哦，天哪。因为底部全都是蕾丝，而我把衬裙塞进了内衣里，但更糟糕的是。
What? How can it get worse than you tucked your... Also didn't you fill some air in places you should have been filling air? I was so nervous. You were rushing. I was rushing. You were rushing. Okay, okay, okay. I wanted to get into my friend Steve's big movie premiere. Okay, how does it get worse?
什么？怎么会比你把……更糟糕？而且你还在一些不该充气的地方充了气吗？我太紧张了。你在赶时间。我很赶时间。你在赶时间。好吧，好吧，好吧。我想去参加我朋友史蒂夫的大电影首映式。好吧，怎么个更糟糕法？
You know when you go and you buy like the three pack of cotton underwear at Target. All the time. And there's a white pair, a black pair, a new pair, and then a crazy colored pair. I was wearing the crazy pair. Oh, Jenna. From my Target underwear pack.
你知道当你去塔吉特百货买那种三条装的纯棉内衣时吗？经常买。里面有一条白色的、一条黑色的、一条裸色的，然后还有一条颜色疯狂的。我当时穿的就是那条颜色疯狂的。哦，詹娜。从我的塔吉特内衣套装里拿出来的。
And I think, like, from the back, you must have been able to see it. Thankfully, I didn't turn around on the red carpet, but I'm sure many people saw that as I was walking. Saw it. Jenna, I do not remember if I did the red carpet or not. I don't know if I did. I think I just went in the theater. I mean, I would have to go back and look,
我想，从后面看，你一定能看到它。谢天谢地，我在红毯上没有转身，但我敢肯定我走路的时候很多人都看到了。看到了。詹娜，我不记得我走没走红毯了。我不知道我走没走。我想我只是直接进了影院。我的意思是，我得回去查查看，
but I feel like I didn't even know that we had to do that. And I kind of- Someone made me do it. Like I got out of the car and, you know, someone grabbed me and said, you need to take pictures. And I was- I'm pretty sure I drove myself and I just parked in the garage and I walked in.
但我感觉我甚至不知道我们还得走红毯。我有点……有人逼我走的。就像我刚下车，然后，你知道的，有人抓住我说，你需要去拍照。而我——我确信我是自己开车去的，我把车停在车库里，然后就走进去了。
But I just remember being so excited for Steve and he was so happy we were there. He had us all sitting together and he came over and he gave us all a big hug. And I kind of remember that he wore a white suit. Am I remembering that right? Don't know. Don't know. Should have looked it up. We were doing the Dundee's today. I don't think I bought anything new. I don't remember what I wore. I sat between John and Rain at the premiere when the movie was over. I turned to John and I said, Steve is going to be the biggest movie star when this movie comes out. He's going to stop being Steve. He's going to start being Steve Carell. And it's going to be weird because we know Steve. And the rest of the world is going to know Steve Carell in about one week.
但我只记得我为史蒂夫感到无比兴奋，他看到我们去他真的太高兴了。他让我们所有人都坐在一起，他走过来给了我们每个人一个大大的拥抱。我隐约记得他穿了一套白色的西装。我没记错吧？不知道。不知道。真该查一下的。我们今天在聊《邓迪奖》。我当时好像没买什么新衣服。我不记得我穿了什么了。首映式散场时，我坐在约翰和雷恩之间。我转过身对约翰说：“这部电影上映后，史蒂夫要成为最大的电影明星了。他不再只是史蒂夫了。他要成为史蒂夫·卡瑞尔了。这会感觉很奇怪，因为我们认识史蒂夫。而世界上其他人将在大约一周内认识史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。”
I remember thinking like, holy moly, this is going to be a big hit. So now we're shooting the Dundies. Yes. The 40-year-old Virgin has come out. And as predicted, Steve Carell. He's a huge movie star. And since we're on location, they had to economize space.
我记得当时想：天哪，这绝对会大火。所以现在我们正在拍摄《邓迪奖》。对。《四十岁的老处男》已经上映了。正如预期的那样，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。他成了超级大电影明星。由于我们是在外景地拍摄，他们不得不节省空间。
And we were each given these teeny, teeny, tiny trailers. To change clothes in, basically. That's all you could do. That's all you could do is about the size of a closet. Even Steve, biggest movie star in the country, did not get a larger closet to change in. And his was infested with ants. Ew! And I will just never forget how humble he was and how he did not complain at all. Well, he's- And I thought, you know what?
我们每个人都被分到了这种超级无敌小的拖车。基本上就是用来换衣服的。你只能这么做。你只能做的事就是呆在衣柜大小的空间里。就连史蒂夫这个全国最大的电影明星，也没有得到更大的换衣间。而且他的拖车里还全是蚂蚁。呃！我永远不会忘记他是多么的谦逊，他一点也没有抱怨。好吧，他——我当时想，你知道吗？
That is how you behave with class. Yes. And Steve is not a complainer. And he's professional and he's on time and he gets his shiitake done. And he even joked about it. He was like, well, that's how they keep you humble in this business. It was great. It was so great.
这才是有风度的表现。是的。史蒂夫从不抱怨。他很专业，很准时，而且能把事情办妥。他甚至还拿这件事开玩笑。他说：“好吧，这就是在这个行业里保持谦逊的方式。”这太棒了。真的太棒了。
I have a fourth fast fact, Angela. But Jenna, you only do three fast facts. But this is the Dundee's. The Dundee's deserves a fourth fast fact. Okay. So fast fact number four, and this was based on a lot of questions from fans about the Chili's location. It was not a real Chili's.
我还有第四个冷知识，安吉拉。但是詹娜，你不是通常只说三个冷知识吗？但这是《邓迪奖》。《邓迪奖》值得拥有第四个冷知识。好吧。所以冷知识之四，这是基于粉丝们关于奇利餐厅外景地的很多提问。那不是真正的奇利餐厅。
In fact, it was an out of business restaurant. We got permission from Chili's to make it a Chili's. And they sent all their gear, all their signs and their chalkboard stuff to make it look like a Chili's. Yes, they spent weeks, Michael Gallenberg, our set designer, spent weeks conferring with Chili's, reconstructing with painstaking detail this Chili's restaurant, which was in an abandoned former restaurant.
事实上，那是一家已经倒闭的餐厅。我们得到了奇利餐厅的允许，把它伪装成了一家奇利餐厅。他们把所有的装备、所有的招牌和黑板装饰都寄了过来，让它看起来就像一家奇利餐厅。是的，他们花了几个星期的时间，我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦贝格花了数周时间与奇利餐厅协商，以极其精确的细节重建了这家奇利餐厅，它其实是一家废弃的旧餐厅。
It was in an abandoned restaurant and an empty parking lot. And it, I mean, it didn't even have any signs or anything on it when they started. It was just a out of business restaurant. Yeah. So there you go, guys. You can't, and that what's crazy about that is you can't go eat at that Chili's. It is near a mall. And on my lunch break, I wanted a mask and snorkel and I went. What?
它位于一家废弃的餐厅和一个空停车场里。而且，我的意思是，他们刚开始的时候上面甚至没有任何招牌之类的东西。它只是一家倒闭的餐厅。所以就是这样，伙计们。你不能——关于那件事最疯狂的是，你根本不能去那家奇利餐厅吃饭。它在一个商场附近。在午休时间，我想买呼吸管和潜水面镜，然后我就去了。什么？
Yeah, so this is a story that's not that interesting. But when we film, listen, we filmed at this random neighborhood, this out of business restaurant and I just happened to see that it was near like a mall and I was able on my lunch break to get a snorkel and a mask. For what reason? I wanted to go snorkeling. I was going to go. But this is what I remember about this restaurant.
对，所以这是一个没那么有趣的故事。但当我们拍摄时，听着，我们在一个随机的街区拍摄，在一个倒闭的餐厅里，我碰巧看到它附近好像有个商场，于是我在午休时间买到了潜水面镜和呼吸管。有什么理由吗？我想去浮潜。我本来打算去的。但这正是我对那家餐厅的记忆。
It's like, oh, that's the restaurant. Snorkeling where? It's like in the ocean, Jenna. I was going to go to Catalina Island. Listen, the details aren't important. What is important is when I think about that out of business restaurant that we filmed in as the Chili's is that that's near where I bought my mask and snorkel. Do you still have your mask and snorkel? It broke. Here's the thing guys, if you want to not eat at that Chili's and also buy a broken mask and snorkel, a kind of crappy mask
感觉就是，“哦，那是那家餐厅。”去哪儿浮潜？就在海里啊，詹娜。我本来打算去卡特琳娜岛的。听着，细节并不重要。重要的是，当我想到我们作为奇利餐厅拍摄的那家倒闭的餐厅时，那就在我买面镜和呼吸管的地方附近。你还留着你的面镜和呼吸管吗？坏了。事情是这样的，伙计们，如果你既不想去那家奇利餐厅吃饭，又想买一个坏了的面镜和呼吸管——一个质量有点烂的面镜和呼吸管，你可以去那个地方找找。我想它在全景城。
and snorkel, you can head out to wherever that was. I think it was in Panorama City. Deep in the valleys of Los Angeles. You want to take a break? Yeah, let's take a break. And then we'll get into this episode. We have so much to say. We have so much to say and I have all my note cards. Some of them are really great. Some of them, I don't know guys. Some of them are just a mask and snorkel. Did you see?
位于洛杉矶的山谷深处。你想休息一下吗？好吧，我们休息一下吧。然后我们就开始聊这一集。我们要说的话太多了。我们要说的话太多了，我带着所有的笔记卡。有些真的很棒。有些，我不知道，伙计们。有些只跟面镜和呼吸管有关。看到了吗？
Oh, well, listen. That means stud. Oh, okay. Well, do you want to talk more about the ants in the trailer? The ants in the trailer were interesting. You want to tell another riveting insect story? We'll be right back. McDonald's has the gift that keeps giving.
哦，好吧，听着。那意味着帅哥。哦，好吧。怎么，你想多聊聊拖车里的蚂蚁吗？拖车里的蚂蚁挺有意思的。你想讲另一个引人入胜的昆虫故事吗？我们马上回来。麦当劳有送之不尽的礼物。
To Peter, your dog sitter, and Claire, who shovels your stairs. And to you, when you spend $25 on McDonald's gift cards in restaurants, get a coupon for a free Big Mac or McChicken. See details at participating McDonald's restaurants. Bumble knows it's hard to start conversations. Hey. No, too basic. Hi there. Still no. What about hello, handsome? Ugh, who knew you could
送给你的宠物狗保姆彼得，帮你铲楼梯雪的克莱尔。当你花 25 美元购买麦当劳餐厅礼品卡时，还能获赠免费巨无霸或麦香鸡的优惠券。详情请参见参与活动的麦当劳餐厅。Bumble 深知开启对话有多难。嘿。不，太基础了。你好呀。还是不行。帅哥，你好怎么样？呃，谁知道你能把自己恶心到？
give yourself the ick? That's why Bumble is changing how you start conversations. You can now make the first move or not. With opening moves, you simply choose a question to be automatically sent to your matches. Then sit back and let your matches start the chat. Download Bumble and try it for yourself. Sephora's biggest fragrance sale of the year is on. Get 20% off full-size fragrance gifts, including designer scents like Valentino Dona, born in Roma.
这就是为什么 Bumble 正在改变你开启对话的方式。你现在可以主动出击，也可以不。通过“开场白”，你只需选择一个问题，系统就会自动发送给你的匹配对象。然后坐下来，让你的匹配对象开启聊天。下载 Bumble 并亲自体验一下吧。丝芙兰一年中最大规模的香水促销活动正在进行中。购买正装香水礼品可享 8 折优惠，包括瓦伦蒂诺罗马之梦等设计师香水。
How did you know? 20% off floral scents like Burberry Her. Thank you. And 20% off trending scents like Kayali Yum Bougie Marshmallow and Glossier You. This is perfect. 20% off full-size fragrances now through December 24th. Shop now at Sephora and Sephora at Kohl's. So you guys, we were going to a break and while we went to a break, I Googled Jenna's
你怎么知道的？博柏利她的花香调香水享 8 折优惠。谢谢。还有卡亚利香甜马卡龙棉花糖和 Glossier You 等热门香水享 8 折优惠。这太完美了。正装香水 8 折优惠，活动持续至 12 月 24 日。立即在丝芙兰和科尔士百货内的丝芙兰选购。所以大家，我们刚刚要去休息，而在休息期间，我谷歌了一下詹娜在《四十岁的老处男》首映式上的裙子，我明白你的意思了。你看它为什么有点像美人鱼。它确实有点像美人鱼。你知道我为什么那样描述它了。而且看起来就像是有人在你摆姿势时告诉你：“把手叉在腰上，胸脯稍微挺起来。”对。看看你的姿势。
dress at the 40-year-old virgin and I see what you mean. You see how it's kind of mermaidy. It is kind of mermaidy. You see why I described it that way. It also looks like this is like someone told you when you pose, stick your arms on your hips and stick your chest out a little. Yeah. Look at your pose.
看看那个。你就像是“轰”的一声登场了。好吧，我想说的是，除了参加首映式，安吉拉，你还记得你和我一起第二次去看这部电影吗？就我们两个，作为最好的朋友，我们在大厅里跟史蒂夫的海报合了影。我们自己去的，因为我们太为史蒂夫高兴了。我还留着呢。
Look at that. You're like kaboom. Well, I want to say that in addition to attending the premiere, Angela, do you remember that you and I went and saw it a second time together, just the two of us, as BFFs, and we took a picture with Steve's poster in the lobby. We went on our own because we were just so excited for Steve. I still have it.
我有一张照片，是你和我站在电影院海报上他的脸旁边。我敢那会儿人们肯定在想：“那两个人在搞什么鬼？”我们要不要进入这一集？安吉拉继续在手机里翻看我在这场首映式上拍的照片，找我那条疯狂的塔吉特内衣，我敢肯定是这样的。
I have a photo of you and I standing next to his face on a poster in the movie theater. I'm sure people were like, what are those two up to? Should we get into this episode as Angela continues to scroll through pictures of me at this premiere looking for my crazy Target underwear, I'm sure.
哦，史蒂夫确实穿了一套白色的西装。他穿了一套白色西装。我没记错。根本没有我的照片。好吧，让我们进入这一集。在帕姆坐在办公桌前的第一个镜头里，我不知道你有没有注意到这一点，安吉拉，作为我们的背景专家，
Oh, Steve did wear a white suit. He wore a white suit. I remembered that correctly. There are no photos for me. All right, let's get into this episode. In the very opening shot of Pam at her desk, I don't know if you noticed this, Angela, as our background expert,
但我手里正拿着我的工作鞋。我刚到公司，手里拿着工作鞋，这是我们做过但没有明说的一个细节。这是为了确定她上班时穿白色的 Keds 运动鞋，然后换上她的工作鞋。很多人都这样。很多人都这样。很多住在纽约市、靠步行或坐地铁出行的人都这样。我不确定为什么由未婚夫开车送去上班的帕姆，需要在车里穿 Keds。所以就是这样。好吧，也许帕姆只有一双好看的鞋子，她不想把它弄脏。
but I am holding my work shoes in my hand. I've just arrived at work and I'm holding my work shoes and this was something that we did but did not mention. It was to establish that she wears her white Keds to work and then changes into her work shoes. Which a lot of people do. A lot of people do. A lot of people who live in New York City and walk or use the subway. I'm not sure why Pam, who is driven to work by her fiance, needs to wear Keds in the car. So it is. Well, maybe Pam only has the one pair of shoes that are her nice shoes and she doesn't want to
好吧，这就是为什么她的 Keds 能保持得那么白，因为她只在车里穿，以防你想知道。好吧，接下来是迈克尔的采访镜头，描述邓迪奖。每个人都写信来讨论这个。为什么史蒂夫在本集他的第一个镜头里看起来这么不一样？好吧，我知道为什么，因为当他——他准备拍摄《四十岁的老处男》的那个夏天，
muck them up. Well, this is how she keeps her Keds so white is because she just wears them in a car, in case you were wondering. All right, so moving on to Michael's talking head, describing the Dundies. Everyone wrote in about this. Why does Steve look so different in the first shot of him in this episode? Well, I know why, because when he, the summer that he was gonna film 40-year-old Virgin,
他的身材练得好得惊人。棒极了。身材棒极了。然后他一直保持着那个状态。他拍摄《四十岁的老处男》时身材好得惊人。棒极了。身材棒极了。然后他一直保持着那个状态。他现在整个人非常健美。他有点把这融入了自己的生活。他们还给他换了全新造型。他们把他打扮了一番。
he got in crazy amazing shape. Amazing shape. Amazing shape, and then he's maintained that film 40 year old Virgin, he got in crazy amazing shape. Amazing shape. Amazing shape. And then he's maintained that. He's just like, he's very fit now. He sort of like made that part of his life. They just gave him a whole new look too. They zhuzhed him up.
好吧，原本他的角色是基于英国原版剧集和那里的老板。所以他的外形很大程度上是在模仿大卫·布伦特。而当史蒂夫回来时，整个人苗条了那么多，看起来棒极了，他们就顺势利用了这一点。对，我的意思是，他看起来很健康。他看起来很健康。他太棒了。还有，第一季的时候，我知道他们在他的头发里抹了发胶，他们把它往后梳，看起来像大卫·布伦特。对。然后在那之后，他们说：“好吧，让我们换个发型吧。”然后其实詹娜和我，你们知道的，我们当时在聊这个，因为这能把我们逗乐。
Well, originally his character was based on the British show and the boss there. So they really mirrored his look after David Brent. And when Steve came back, so much thinner and just looking amazing, they used it as an excuse. Yeah, I mean, he just looked healthy. He looked healthy. He was great. Also, the first season, I know they put this gel in his hair, they like slicked it back to look like David Brent. Right. And then and then after that, they're like, okay, let's style his hair different. And then Jen and I actually, you guys, we were talking about this because this would crack us up.
男演员们在发型和化妆拖车里都有他们自己的美发工具。其中之一就是一个极小的滚刷，他们会用它把头发吹出一点微卷的蓬松发型。但那个刷子真的很小。而且布莱恩和雷恩有——还记得那个超级无敌小的直板夹吗？那是最小的直板夹？它小得能放进口袋里。简直像个笑话。它看起来就像个拆信刀。
The guys had all their own hair accessories and hair and makeup trailer. And one of them was like the tiniest little rolling brush that they would get their hair blown out like a little bouffant. But it was really tiny. And Brian and Rain had, remember that teeny tiny little flat iron. It's the tiniest flat iron? It could fit in your pocket. It was like a joke. It looked like an envelope opener.
是的，太小了。他们会用它来夹他们那细小的刘密。为什么男士们都有这种微型的、几乎像是给洋娃娃用的东西？看起来就是那样。太诡异了。不过，是的，这完全改变了史蒂夫的外表，而且史蒂夫自己也刚刚练就了惊人的身材。
Yes, it was so small. And they would flat iron their tiny bangs. Why did the men all have these like miniature, like almost something you would use on a doll? That's what it looked like. It was so weird. But yeah, so it totally changed the way Steve looked and Steve himself had just gotten an amazing shape.
是的，太小了。而且他们会用平板夹板夹他们细小的刘海。为什么男人们都有这种微型的、几乎就像是给洋娃娃用的一样的东西？看起来就是那样。太奇怪了。不过是的，所以这完全改变了史蒂夫的外表，史蒂夫自己也刚刚拥有了极好的身材。
Well, we also a little bit adjusted the character of Michael Scott as well, finally. I think they felt like when they got the pick up for season two, they could really make this for Steve. They could really base it more on what Steve was gonna bring to the character. And for example, in this episode later, we'll talk about it, Michael gets hazed, and you see him really wounded. And that was a choice. That was a choice to make Michael a little bit more, I don't know, sympathetic. Well, I feel like in season two, they started
73|||嗯，最后我们对迈克尔·斯科特的性格也做了一点调整。我觉得他们觉得当第二季续订时，他们可以真正为史蒂夫量身打造这个角色。他们可以更多地根据史蒂夫将为这个角色带来什么来塑造它。比如，在这集后面的部分我们会聊到，迈克尔被整蛊了，你看到他真的很受伤。这是一个选择。这是一个选择，让迈克尔变得稍微，我不知道，更有同情心一点。嗯，我觉得在第二季，他们开始
doing a thing with Michael's character. And I'm sure you guys watching notice this as well, is that as awkward and cringy as he could be and really not aware of the things he said and how they affected people, they would give him one moment that was redeeming. One moment in the episode where you rooted for him or felt bad for him so that it wasn't just all like, oh, that guy is such a jerk.
74|||对迈克尔的性格做了一件事。我相信你们这些观众也注意到了这一点，那就是尽管他可能会表现得很尴尬、很窘迫，对自己的言论以及它们如何影响别人完全没有意识，但他们会给他一个能展现他好一面的时刻。剧中的一个时刻，你会为他加油或者为他感到难过，这样他就不会全都是“哦，这家伙真是个混蛋”。
Instead of the onslaught of insults that season one had been. Right. They just made him have one of insults that season one had been. Right. They just made him have one moment where you were just sympathetic towards him. So I hope that solves the mystery for all of you about why did Steve suddenly look different. So next we have Pam's talking head about the Dundies.
75|||而不是第一季那种铺天盖地的侮辱。没错。他们只是让他拥有一个让人对他产生同情心的时刻。所以我希望这能为你们所有人解开谜团，解开为什么史蒂夫突然看起来不一样了。接下来是帕姆关于邓迪奖的访谈。
She's sitting in the conference room. And Pam has so much residual anger. Do you see how deeply angry she is about the Dundies? And also, though, the Dundies just keep poking that wound about her engagement. Yes. Oh, yeah. And then we move on to the scene where Pam, Meredith, and Kelly are laughing about how someone wrote something on the bathroom wall in the ladies' room about Michael.
76|||她坐在会议室里。帕姆有着如此多的残留怒火。你们看到她对邓迪奖有多么深深的愤怒了吗？而且，不过，邓迪奖也不断在触动她订婚这件事的伤口。是的。哦，是的。然后我们转到帕姆、梅雷迪思和凯莉在女洗手间里笑谈有人在浴室墙上写了关于迈克尔的话的场景。
Yes. And this is funny. Mindy said people always talk about how the Dundies is about an award show but she thinks it's also a mystery about who wrote on the bathroom wall. You guys were like oh it's just something funny and then Dwight's like what was it Dave Barry? He is like a humorist he had a column in the Miami Herald that became a TV show called Dave's World. Oh yeah! So that is who Rain would consider... That was his go-to funny.
77|||是的。这很有趣。明迪说人们总是在谈论邓迪奖是一个颁奖典礼，但她认为这也是一个关于谁在浴室墙上留言的悬疑故事。你们当时就觉得，哦，这只是件搞笑的事，然后德怀特就说，那是戴夫·巴里吗？他是个幽默作家，他在《迈阿密先驱报》上有个专栏，后来改编成了一部名为《戴夫的世界》的电视剧。哦，是的！所以这就是雷恩会认为是……那是他信手拈来的搞笑点。
Yeah, go-to funny person. Did you notice in that scene that Kelly is still not fully transformed? She's getting there, though. Her hair is now half up, half down. Yes, she's getting there, and she had some brighter lipstick on. But she still has that high-neck Paisley blouse.
78|||是的，张口就来的搞笑人物。你有没有注意到那个场景里凯莉还没有完全大变样？不过她快了。她的头发现在是半扎半放的。是的，她快了，她还涂了一些亮一点的口红。但她仍然穿着那件高领佩斯利花纹衬衫。
And also, did you notice that Mindy is basically laughing through the entire scene? Yes. And I thought, you know what, when I watched it, I was like, how happy was Mindy that she was allowed to laugh? Because she was going to be laughing anyway. Yes, Mindy laughed through all of her acting takes. A lot of them. A lot of them. Yeah. So I thought she must have been just so tickled
79|||还有，你有没有注意到明迪基本上整场戏都在笑？是的。我想，你知道吗，当我看到它时，我在想，明迪被允许笑该有多高兴啊？因为她反正都会笑的。是的，明迪在拍摄她所有的戏份时都在笑。很多次。很多次。是的。所以我想她一定是非常开心
that she got to be laughing. So the next scene is Michael's on his phone call call with Jan where he throws the camera out of his office I loved that I did I love that. He throws the camera out get out get out. Yes, and She is giving him trouble because you know, she says we're not gonna pay for the Dundee's this year She also lists what she considers some of his failed parties Which were the, she was like, you just threw a party on May 5th and he goes, it was 05-05-05. It happens once every billion years.
80|||能有机会笑出来。所以下一个场景是迈克尔在和简通电话，期间他把摄像机扔出了办公室，我太喜欢这个了，我是真的喜欢。他把摄像机扔出去，滚出去，滚出去。是的，她在找他的麻烦，因为你知道的，她说我们今年不会为邓迪奖买单了。她还列举了她认为他的一些失败派对，其中包括，她说，你刚刚在5月5号办了一个派对，然后他说，那是05-05-05。每十亿年才发生一次。
And then she goes, in a luau, you threw a luau. And then she was like, and you had a tsunami relief fundraiser that lost money. Oh, by the way, by the way, he goes, no, it wasn't a fundraiser. It was a fundraiser. Yeah. And then Michael has a talking head where he puts the envelope to his head, which is a riff on a bit that Johnny Carson used to do
81|||然后她说，办了一个露奥派对，你办了一个露奥派对。接着她说，你还有一个亏了钱的海啸救灾募捐活动。哦，顺便说一句，顺便说一句，他说，不，这不是募捐活动。这是一个募捐活动。是的。然后迈克尔有一个访谈镜头，他把信封贴在额头上，这是对强尼·卡森过去常做的一个梗的致敬。
on the Tonight Show. Greg told us that the joke that Michael does in the scene with the envelope was the first joke that Greg ever wrote. Really? He wrote it as a kid. He wrote it for his dad. Oh. Who used to do a presentation at work when Greg was younger.
82|||在今夜秀上。格里格告诉我们，迈克尔在有信封的那个场景中开的玩笑是格里格写过的第一个笑话。真的吗？他小时候写的。他为他爸爸写的。哦。在格里格年轻的时候，他爸爸曾在工作时做过一个演讲。
Yeah. He did a riff. His dad did a riff for his own employees. On Johnny Carson. Yeah. And so Greg put it in this episode. That is adorable. Yeah.
83|||是的。他抛了一个梗。他爸爸为他自己的员工抛了一个梗。关于强尼·卡森的。是的。所以格里格把这个放进了这一集里。太可爱了。是的。
That is adorable. So then we have the scene where Dwight is sneaking into the woman's restroom. And he goes in, but he doesn't realize Phyllis is still there and she throws him out. Can you see Rain breaking? Yes, look at my note card. He is almost breaking. He's almost breaking.
84|||太可爱了。所以接下来是德怀特溜进女洗手间的场景。他进去了，但他没有意识到菲利丝还在里面，菲利丝把他赶了出来。你能看出雷恩笑场了吗？是的，看我的笔记卡。他快要笑场了。他快要笑场了。
I have, when Phyllis chases Dwight out of the bathroom, look at that, Rain is about to laugh. For sure. For sure. I love that though, Phyllis just owned him in that moment. It was so great. So I have a note card because this cracked me up. At seven minutes, nine seconds, Dwight gets everyone's attention. He's very mad at the ladies of the office, right?
85|||我有，当菲利丝把德怀特赶出浴室时，看那个，雷恩快要笑了。绝对是的。绝对是的。不过我喜欢那样，菲利丝在那一刻完全压制了他。太棒了。所以我有一张笔记卡，因为这把我逗乐了。在七分零九秒，德怀特引起了所有人的注意。他非常生办公室女职员的气，对吧？
And he makes this announcement. And when he comes out to make this announcement, the camera shot starts over Stanley's shoulder and Stanley is playing with a toy car. He is holding a bright blue toy car. It's a convertible. The doors are open on it, like he's been opening the doors and he holds this blue convertible toy car throughout the scene and you see it a few times. And I was like, what is that? What is that?
86|||他发表了这个声明。当他出来发表这个声明时，镜头从斯坦利的肩膀上方开始，斯坦利正在玩一个玩具车。他拿着一辆亮蓝色的玩具汽车。它是一个敞篷车。车门开着，就像他一直在开车门一样，他在整个场景中一直拿着这辆蓝色的敞篷玩具车，你看到了好几次。当时我就想，那是什么？那是什么？
I don't know, but it cracked me up. And I remember that he had some cars on his desk. Do you remember that? I don't. I don't know why I forgot that Dwight had bobbleheads, but I know that Stanley has like cars. Something that never becomes a plot point is snowed in your brain. And not a plot point to my character.
87|||我不知道，但这把我逗乐了。我记得他的桌上有一些车。你记得吗？我不记得了。我不知道为什么我忘了德怀特有摇头娃娃，但我知道斯坦利有类似汽车的东西。一个从未成为剧情要点的事情却深深印在你的脑海里。而且对我这个角色来说也不是剧情要点。
Specifically. I know. Well, did you notice Angela that in the background of that same scene, if you look at Meredith's computer, you can see she's in the middle of a free cell game. Oh, no, I didn't see that. Yes. In later seasons after we got internet and we stopped playing free cell, we would get in trouble if we had unapproved things on our screens.
88|||特别指出。我知道。好吧，安吉拉，你有没有注意到在同一场景的背景中，如果你看梅雷迪思的电脑，你可以看到她正在玩空当接龙游戏。哦，不，我没看到。是的。在后面的季节里，在我们有了互联网并不再玩空当接龙之后，如果我们屏幕上有未经批准的东西，我们就会惹上麻烦。
Oh yeah, I do. The camera guys would say, Angela, we can totally see your email account. I'd be like, okay. Or if you were looking at a website, there were certain things that we were allowed to show on computer screens like fake documents, the Dunder Mifflin logo, free sell games, I guess we got that cleared. But we couldn't have other stuff and we would get yelled at.
89|||哦，是的，我确实。摄像师会说，安吉拉，我们完全可以看到你的电子邮件账户。我会说，好吧。或者如果你在看一个网站，有些东西是被允许在电脑屏幕上显示的，比如伪造的文件、邓德米夫林的标志、空当接龙游戏，我想我们已经获准这样做了。但我们不能有其他东西，我们会挨训的。
And then Rain said, you never have to tell me again about the screens. All right? Stop hounding me about the screens. In fact, if you ever find something on my screen while we're shooting that's not allowed to be there, I will donate $100 to charity every time. Why was he so annoyed? He had such a bean as bought it. He had to pay out so much because he would forget. Oh, and the camera guys would hold him to it. Yes, because he made this big declaration.
90|||然后雷恩说，你再也不用跟我提屏幕的事了。好吗？别再拿屏幕的事来烦我了。事实上，如果在我们拍摄时你发现我的屏幕上有任何不被允许出现的东西，我每次都会向慈善机构捐款100美元。他为什么这么烦？他对此真是太较真了。他不得不支付好多罚款，因为他会忘。哦，摄像师会以此来约束他。是的，因为他发表了这份宏大的声明。
Well, good for them. You never need to tell me again. And water bottles, we used to get in trouble for having soda cans or whatever on our desks. I mean, you don't watch Game of Thrones, but there was a Starbucks coffee cup that really. I don't watch Game of Thrones, and yet I did get into the coffee gate situation. Yeah.
91|||好吧，这倒怪不得他们。你再也不需要提醒我了。还有水瓶，我们以前因为桌上有苏打罐什么的而惹上麻烦。我的意思是，你虽然不看《权力的游戏》，但那里确实有一个星巴克的咖啡杯。我不看《权力的游戏》，然而我还是卷入了咖啡门事件。是的。
I thought, how in the world? How do they miss that? I mean, there's a Starbucks coffee thing next to like a dragon on the ground. I mean, that's a whole other world. There are not even Starbucks in that world. At least if we left a Starbucks on our desk, you could be like, well, I guess they went to Starbucks.
92|||我想，这到底是怎么回事？他们怎么会错过那个？我的意思是，地上的一条龙旁边居然有一个星巴克咖啡杯。我的意思是，那是完全另一个世界。那个世界里甚至没有星巴克。至少如果我们把星巴克留在桌上，你还可以说，好吧，我猜他们去星巴克了。
Yeah. I just have to say something that in watching this again made me laugh out loud is that Michael is trying to make everyone feel good about the Dundee's. He's so wounded that people aren't excited. This clearly means so much to him. And he can't believe that no one else shares his enthusiasm for the Dundee's, he's so wounded that people aren't excited. This clearly means so much to him. And he can't believe that no one else shares his enthusiasm for the Dundee's and sees how important they are. So as a way to try to like get them back into it, he says, listen, friends and family are
93|||是的。我必须说一件事，再次看这个片段时让我哈哈大笑，那就是迈克尔正试图让每个人都对邓迪奖感觉良好。看到大家并不兴奋，他感到非常受伤。这显然对他意义重大。他简直不敢相信竟然没有其他人分享他对邓迪奖的热情，看到大家并不兴奋，他感到非常受伤。这显然对他意义重大。他简直不敢相信竟然没有其他人分享他对邓迪奖的热情并看到它们有多重要。所以作为一种试图让他们重拾兴致的方式，他说，听着，朋友和家人
invited to the Dundee's for the first time. For the first time? Do you mean like all these years that he's been doing the dundies, he's never let them bring plus ones? I couldn't believe that. I was like, what? And everyone is like, Oh, great. Everyone is like genuinely happy about it. Yes. I was like, Oh my gosh, it was like employees only. Oh, and then later you realize that no one is paid for that everyone now their bill is going be double. Double. Because they brought a plus one.
94|||有史以来第一次被邀请参加邓迪奖。第一次？你是说他举办邓迪奖这么多年来，从来没允许他们带女伴/男伴来？我简直不敢相信。当时我就想，什么？每个人都觉得，哦，太棒了。每个人都由衷地感到高兴。是的。当时我想，哦天哪，这就像是仅限员工参加一样。哦，然后后来你意识到没有人为此付过钱，现在每个人的账单都要翻倍了。翻倍。因为他们带了女伴/男伴。
And they wouldn't have probably even brought anyone. So now guys, we are gonna move to the Chili's. Oh, here we go. It's time to go to Chili's. Here we go. And if we look like we're sweating, it's because it was over 100 degrees when we shot this episode and there was very little air conditioning inside this abandoned restaurant. I'm absolutely fine because when I'm completely comfortable, everyone is miserable.
95|||而且他们可能甚至都不会带任何人来。好了，伙计们，我们要去Chili's餐厅了。哦，来吧。是时候去Chili's了。我们走吧。如果我们看起来在流汗，那是因为我们拍这一集的时候温度超过了100华氏度，而且这个废弃的餐厅里面几乎没有空调。我绝对很好，因为当我感到完全舒适时，每个人都在受折磨。
So I was doing okay as well, but the gentleman, the men wearing suits were poor. Well, poor Steve, I mean, tuxedo. And then he would put things on top of the tuxedo. Yeah. Yeah. We spent three full days filming there. And we also had to sometimes wear coats because we were pretending like it was fall. If you see Rain, he's got that big trench coat on. It always worked out that way. We would film all these episodes that we'll talk about where we were in coats and suits and stuff outside and it was August.
96|||所以我当时也还好，但是那些绅士们，穿着西装的男人们可就惨了。好吧，可怜的史蒂夫，我的意思是，燕尾服。然后他会在燕尾服上面加一些东西。是的。是的。我们在那里花了整整三天时间拍摄。而且我们有时还得穿外套，因为我们要假装现在是秋天。如果你看雷恩，他穿着那件厚重的大风衣。总是这样安排。我们会拍摄所有这些我们等会儿要聊的集数，我们在外面穿着外套和西装之类的，而当时其实是八月。
Or we would have to pretend like it was spring, but we were shooting it during the winter and we would be freezing. Yes. We never shot the episodes during the time of year in which they were. I love Oscar's talking head, his description of the Dundies, comparing them to a children's party. He did that so well. It was so spot on.
97|||或者我们必须假装是春天，但我们却是在冬天拍摄，冷得要命。是的。我们从来没有在一年中对应的季节拍摄过这些剧集。我喜欢奥斯卡的访谈，他对比了邓迪奖和一个儿童派对，对邓迪奖的描述。他演得太棒了。简直太贴切了。
Oscar always has some of my favorite talking heads. He's brilliant. He's an amazing actor. He really is. Oscar describes the Dundies as a child's birthday party and Pam compares it to an accident that you're forced to look at. You're forced to look at.
98|||奥斯卡总是有一些我最喜欢的访谈。他太棒了。他是个了不起的演员。真的是这样。奥斯卡把邓迪奖描述为一个孩子的生日派对，而帕姆把它比作一场你被迫去看的事故。你被迫去看的事故。
I have a question for you, Jenna. Yeah. All right. I read, when I was looking back over the Dundies, I read an article that said that BJ Novak took Jenna out to get drunk in real life and then let her know what her responses were like because you don't really drink that much in real life. So he took you out drinking. Is that true? Yes. What? Yes. I was nervous about this episode because Pam had
99|||我有个问题问你，珍娜。是的。好吧。我读到过，当我回看邓迪奖时，我读到过一篇文章，上面说B·J·诺瓦克在现实生活中带珍娜出去喝酒，然后让她知道自己的反应是什么样的，因为你在现实生活中其实不怎么喝酒。所以他带你出去喝酒了。这是真的吗？是的。什么？是的。我对这一集很紧张，因为帕姆必须
to be drunk. And that's hard to play and not be goofy. It is. And I confided in the writers goofy. It is. And I confided in the writers and I said, I'm nervous. I don't know how to do it. And Mindy had a great stage direction later where she was saying, you know, Pam is nodding along. I loved that. Nodding. That was not, that was in the script that Pam is nodding when she's really drunk. Right. Then you're trying so hard to pay attention. Yes. Exactly. I'm a normal person paying attention. Yes. Look how I'm nodding at she's really drunk. Right, then you're trying so hard to pay attention. Yes, exactly. I'm a normal person paying attention. Yes, look how I'm nodding at you.
100|||喝醉。这很难演，又不能显得滑稽可笑。确实很难。我向编剧倾诉了滑稽可笑。确实很难。我向编剧倾诉了并且我说，我很紧张。我不知道该怎么演。明迪后来有一个很棒的舞台调度，她说，你知道的，帕姆一直在点头。我太喜欢那个了。点头。那不是，剧本里写的就是帕姆喝醉时会点头。对。然后你一直在努力集中注意力。是的。没错。我是一个正在集中注意力的正常人。是的。看我怎么向你点头她喝醉了。对，然后你努力地想要集中注意力。是的，没错。我是一个正常人在集中注意力。是的，看我怎么对你点头。
So that was Mindy's stage direction. But the rest of it, like, how do you gradually become drunk? And I was really afraid that I was going to do just some horrible fake, drunken performance. You did fantastic. Thank you. So BJ and I get to talking, and we decide, how about we go out, I'll have some drinks, and BJ will ask me questions and help me observe what it feels like to slowly get drunk. So he was sort of going to document you having drinks.
101|||所以那是明迪的舞台调度。但其余的部分，比如，你是如何逐渐喝醉的？我真的很害怕我会做出一些可怕的虚假醉酒表演。你表现得棒极了。谢谢。所以我和B·J·诺瓦克聊了起来，我们决定，要不我们出去吧，我喝点酒，然后B·J会问我问题，帮我观察慢慢喝醉是什么感觉。所以他有点像要记录你喝酒的过程。
Yes. This is really method. This is super nerdy. I like it though. And I know why I didn't take you out because I would have been the one also being like, I'll have drinks too. And like, no, this defeats the purpose. This is a scientific experiment. So yeah, so I went out with BJ, and it was really interesting
102|||是的。这真的很方法派。这超级书呆子气。不过我挺喜欢的。我知道我为什么没带你出去，因为我也会是那种说“我也要喝一杯”的人，然后就会说，不，这就违背初衷了。这是一场科学实验。所以，是的，我和B·J出去了，这真的很有趣
because after the first two drinks, I was like, oh, I just feel buzzed and a little dizzy. I was laughing a lot. So that's why I had Pam do all of those ridiculous laughs in the episode. But by drink number four, I was drinking cosmopolitan. Oh my gosh, Jenna. Did you get sick?
103|||因为在前两杯酒之后，我就想，哦，我只是觉得有点微醺，有点头晕。我笑了很多。这就是为什么我在这一集里让帕姆做了所有那些荒谬的笑声。但到了第四杯时，我喝的是大都会鸡尾酒。哦天哪，珍娜。你喝吐了吗？
I didn't get sick. Oh, good Lord. Okay. I know. So by drink number four, apparently I said to BJ, I don't feel drunk at all. I feel normal. And BJ said, really? Because you're talking really loud and really close,
104|||我没有吐。哦，天哪。好吧。我知道。所以到第四杯时，我显然对B·J说，我一点也不觉得醉。我觉得很正常。然后B·J说，真的吗？因为你说话声音很大，离得很近，
and you almost just fell over. I was like, I did? So I stopped after drink number four. But I thought that it was really interesting how after so many drinks, I doubted that I was even drunk. Yes. So all that information, I weaved into my performance. And so all that information, I kind of
105|||而且你刚才差点摔倒。我说，我有吗？所以我喝完第四杯就停下了。但我觉得这真的很有趣，在喝了那么多酒之后，我竟然怀疑自己是不是真的喝醉了。是的。所以所有这些信息，我都融入到了我的表演中。所以所有这些信息，我某种程度上
weaved into my performance. Well, it worked, lady. Thank you. And I'm glad you didn't have a hangover. So folks, drink responsibly. Yeah. Don't drink for Cosmos. Yeah, don't drink for Cosmos.
106|||融入到了我的表演中。好吧，管用了，女士。谢谢。很高兴你没有宿醉。所以各位，饮酒要适量。是的。别为了大都会鸡尾酒狂饮。是的，别为了大都会鸡尾酒狂饮。
We do not recommend. Rain got really into the sound effects on that keyboard. He did. Do you remember that? I do. So they had a keyboard for him, and they Rain got really into the sound effects on that keyboard. He did. So remember that? I do. So they had a keyboard for him, and they told him the different sounds the keyboard made.
107|||我们不推荐。雷恩对那个键盘上的音效非常着迷。他是的。你还记得吗？我记得。所以他们为他准备了一个键盘，而雷恩对那个键盘上的音效非常着迷。他是的。所以你还记得吗？我记得。所以他们为他准备了一个键盘，他们
This is like handing a child a keyboard, or it's like even when you give Rain a microphone. Oh, yeah. Get ready, because he's going to have a lot of bits. They told him he could play it whenever he wanted during Michael's speeches. And did he ever, I mean right out of the gate when when um Michael's like, well Stanley I can't wait to meet your wife and she's like I'm holding her hand right now.
108|||告诉了他键盘发出的各种声音。这就像是把键盘交到一个孩子手上，或者就像你给雷恩一个麦克风一样。哦，是的。准备好吧，因为他会有很多即兴发挥。他们告诉他，在迈克尔演讲期间，他可以随时弹奏。他真的这么做了吗，就在迈克尔说“嗯，斯坦利，我迫不及待想见见你妻子”时，她说“我现在正拉着她的手呢”。
Like that was Rainn improvising like brr brr. Yeah. That was just Rainn having fun on the keyboard. There was also an oh yeah that he used to play. Oh my gosh and and Rain kept doing it at the most inappropriate moments. And that was the thing that would make Steve break more than anything else.
109|||就好像那是雷恩即兴配音说“嘟嘟”一样。是的。那只是雷恩在键盘上玩得很开心。还有一个他经常按的“哦，耶”。哦天哪，雷恩总是在最不合时宜的时刻按这个。比起其他任何东西，这才是真正会让史蒂夫笑场的原因。
It wasn't the fart noise or the trumpet sounds. It was that oh yeah button. And there was one time where Steve broke down laughing. It felt like 10 minutes. He could not get it back. He doubled over. We had to stop filming because he got so tickled because Rain kept hitting that oh yeah button.
110|||不是放屁的声音或小号的声音。而是那个“哦，耶”的按钮。有一次史蒂夫笑得崩溃了。感觉像有10分钟。他就是停不下来。他笑得前俯后仰。我们不得不停止拍摄，因为他实在被逗乐了，而雷恩一直在按那个“哦，耶”按钮。
And Steve never breaks. He is a rock. He and Oscar are the two. Oh. It is very hard to make either of them break. Oh, I would say they were statues for a long time. I was like, Oscar, are you a robot? Let's get into the awards.
111|||而且史蒂夫从来不笑场。他就是一块磐石。他和奥斯卡是那两个。哦。要让他们两个中任何一个笑场都太难了。哦，我会说他们俩很长一段时间里就像雕像一样。当时我都想问，奥斯卡，你是个机器人吗？让我们进入颁奖环节。
There were seven Dundee's given out at this awards. I'm sure there were more given out, but awards. There were seven Dundies given out at this awards. I'm sure there were more given out, but what we witnessed were seven. There was the busiest beaver, which was the busiest beaver to Phyllis. There was hottest in the office to Ryan the temp, awkward. There was the tight ass award given to my character, because not only is she's everybody's favorite stickler, she also has a great caboose. The Spicy Curry Award given to Kelly, and it was actually a bowling award because they had run out of the little men holding briefcases, so she got a bowler.
112|||这次颁奖典礼上颁发了七个邓迪奖。我确信颁发的奖项更多，但颁奖典礼。这次颁奖典礼上颁发了七个邓迪奖。我确信颁发的奖项更多，但我们亲眼见证的是七个。有“最忙碌海狸奖”，颁给了菲利丝。“办公室性感奖”颁给了临时工瑞安，尴尬。还有“小气鬼奖”，颁给了我的角色，因为她不仅是每个人最喜欢的死板教条主义者，她还有一个很棒的臀部。“辛辣咖喱奖”颁给了凯莉，其实这是一个保龄球奖，因为他们用完了那种拿着公文包的小人奖杯，所以她拿到了一个保龄球。
Yeah. And then number five went to Kevin for the Don't Go In There After Me Award. Here's the interesting thing about that. If you look at that Dundee, it's actually a little guy squatting, but it was actually a weightlifting award and they took the dumbbell out of the guy's hands. Oh, that's so smart. So that's what Kevin gets. And then number six is the fine work award given to Stanley.
113|||是的。然后第五个奖项颁给了凯文，获得的是“别在我之后进那间洗手间奖”。关于这个，有趣的地方在于：如果你仔细看那个邓迪奖，其实是一个蹲着的小人，但实际上那是一个举重奖，他们把小人手里的哑铃给拿掉了。哦，太聪明了。所以这就是凯文得到的。然后第六个是颁给斯坦利的“优秀工作奖”。
And number seven, of course, is the whitest sneakers award given to Pam, which brings the house down. So a lot of fans asked this, specifically Courtney asked, what Dundee did Jim get? This is the first Dundee ceremony. We never see him get his award. Jim gets the Jim Halpert Award. That was his Dundee. For just being Jim Halpert.
114|||第七个，当然是颁给帕姆的“最白运动鞋奖”，这把全场气氛推向了高潮。所以很多粉丝都问了这个问题，特别是考特尼问的，吉姆得到了什么邓迪奖？这是第一届邓迪奖典礼。我们从没看到他领奖。吉姆获得了“吉姆·哈尔珀特奖”。这就是他的邓迪奖。因为他就是吉姆·哈尔珀特。
Yeah, it got cut out. But Jim got the Jim Halpert Award. That's awesome. So strange. I think Michael just thinks Jim is cool. Yeah. So you just get an award for being you. Correct. Please be my friend. So you just get an award for being you. Correct.
115|||是的，这部分被剪掉了。但吉姆确实得到了“吉姆·哈尔珀特奖”。太棒了。太奇怪了。我觉得迈克尔只是觉得吉姆很酷。是的。所以你只要做你自己就能得奖。没错。请做我的朋友吧。所以你只要做你自己就能得奖。没错。
Please be my friend. So you talked about Ryan the temp gets the hottest in the office award. He has that great talking head then where he's being asked what he's going to do with his award and he's like, I don't, that is the least of my worries right now. Well when Greg would direct, he would often pull us aside and interview us on the fly. And that talking head was an improvisation. Nice, BJ. BJ improvised that.
116|||请做我的朋友吧。所以你们谈到临时工瑞安获得了办公室性感奖。他随后有那个精彩的访谈，当被问到他打算怎么处理他的奖杯时，他说，我不知道，那是我现在最不担心的事。嗯，当格里格执导时，他经常把我们拉到一边，现场采访我们。那个访谈就是一个即兴发挥。干得好，B·J。B·J是即兴发挥的。
That is awesome. I have some really random cards. When you're ready for random, Jenna, I don't want to mess up your list over there. All right. But when you're ready for random, I have some random cards. I'm ready. You know what? Why don't we take a break and then we'll come back to your random cards.
117|||太棒了。我有一些非常随机的卡片。当你准备好听随机内容时，珍娜，我可不想把你在那边列的清单弄乱。好吧。但当你准备好听随机内容时，我有一些随机卡片。我准备好了。你知道吗？要不我们休息一下，然后再回到你的随机卡片上来。
Okay. And some more info. Really sell it. to your random cards and some more info. Really sell it. My fancy random cards. Yeah, guys, stay with us so you can hear a bunch of random stuff. Hey! Hey, guys, we're back. Are you ready for some random facts, Angela?
118|||好的。还有更多信息。好好宣传一下。回到你的随机卡片和更多信息上来。好好宣传一下。我那些花哨的随机卡片。是的，伙计们，跟我们在一起，这样你们就能听到一堆随机的事情了。嘿！嘿，伙计们，我们回来了。你准备好听一些随机的事实了吗，安吉拉？
All right, here's some random. Creed, I love you, but at 9 minutes 53 seconds, you pick your two. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you.
119|||好吧，这里有一些随机的。克里德，我爱你，但在9分53秒时，你在剔牙。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。
I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. I love you. Hey guys, we're back. Are you ready for some random facts, Angela? All right. Here's some random creed. I love you, but at nine minutes, 53 seconds, you pick your teeth. And I think you did it on purpose. I think it's creed.
120|||我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。嘿伙计们，我们回来了。你准备好听一些随机的事实了吗，安吉拉？好的。这里有一些随机的内容，克里德，我爱你，但在9分53秒时，你在剔牙。而且我觉得你是故意的。我觉得这就是克里德。
You just let your freak fly and you're like, you know what? I'm picking my teeth. It's on camera. It's all good. I love me some creed At nine minutes 58 seconds, I do an enormous Angela eye roll because Michael tells this very lame drunk driving joke, right, about spilling his drink. And I do it a massive eye roll
121|||你只是让你的怪异天性尽情释放，然后你就会想，你知道吗？我在剔牙。这在镜头拍着呢。一切都很好。我太爱克里德了。在9分58秒时，我翻了一个巨大的白眼，因为迈克尔讲了一个非常无聊的酒驾笑话，对吧，关于他洒了饮料。我翻了一个巨大的白眼
and I have been sent that eye roll. Like people text it to me. Oh, wait, are you a meme? I might be, I guess I'm an eye roll meme. So, but yeah. That's exciting. That's exciting. That's exciting. This guys hang with me.
122|||而且有人把那个翻白眼的片段发给我了。等等，你成了一个表情包吗？我可能是吧，我想我成了翻白眼表情包了。所以，好吧。这太让人兴奋了。这太让人兴奋了。这太让人兴奋了。大家听我说。
This could be horrible. But I became obsessed. You know what happens? I get obsessed. So everyone is sitting at tables that kind of makes sense, right? You can sort of see how there's the work friendships. For example, Kelly and Toby are at a table at the Chili's. Roy, Pam and Darryl sit together. Ryan and Jim.
123|||这可能会很糟糕。但我变得痴迷了。你知道会发生什么吗？我变得痴迷了。所以每个人坐的桌子都有点道理，对吧？你可以稍微看出那里存在着工作友谊。例如，凯莉和托比坐在Chili's的一张桌子旁。罗伊、帕姆和达里尔坐在一起。瑞安和吉姆。
When Ryan isn't holding up Michael's cue cards, he goes and sits with Jim. This is before Pam comes back, right? Sure. Sure, the beginning. Creed and Meredith sit together. Stanley is with his wife, Terry. Kevin, I think, is with his fiancee, Stacey.
124|||当瑞安没有帮迈克尔举着提词卡时，他就去和吉姆坐在一起。这是在帕姆回来之前，对吧？当然。当然，一开始是这样的。克里德和梅雷迪思坐在一起。斯坦利和他的妻子特里在一起。凯文，我想，是和他的未婚妻斯黛西在一起。
Stacey. Stacey. Stacey. And Angela's in the corner with Phyllis. But where is Oscar? Where is Oscar? Who is Oscar sitting with, I ask myself? Well, well, at 11 minutes, three seconds, you see that Oscar is sitting between a woman
125|||斯黛西。斯黛西。斯黛西。而安吉拉则和菲利丝坐在角落里。但是奥斯卡在哪里呢？奥斯卡在哪里？我问我自己，奥斯卡和谁坐在一起？好吧，好吧，在11分零3秒时，你看到奥斯卡坐在一个女人
and a man. The woman has long dark hair. Then at 15 minutes, nine seconds, I'm sitting next to Oscar in the booth and Oscar's sitting behind me. And then at 15 minutes, 40 seconds, there's a new man and woman in the booth with Oscar and myself. What? What is happening? I don't know.
126|||和一个男人之间。那个女人留着长长的黑发。然后在15分零9秒时，我坐在卡座里奥斯卡的旁边，奥斯卡坐在我后面。接着在15分40秒时，卡座里多了一个新男人和新女人，和奥斯卡还有我坐在一起。什么？这怎么回事？我不知道。
And then at 15 minutes, 52 seconds, Oscar is between, back between the original woman and man. Then at 17 minutes, 38 seconds, there's a new woman with dark hair and an updo sitting next to Oscar. And I don't know. I don't, it's like, he's like between this woman and man. Then it's like this random woman, this random man, then Oscar, then me.
127|||然后到了15分52秒，奥斯卡又回到了原本的那个女人和男人之间。接着在17分38秒时，有一个留着盘发的新黑发女人坐在奥斯卡旁边。我不知道。我不知道，就好像，他一会儿在这个女人和男人之间。然后又是这个随机的女人，这个随机的男人，然后是奥斯卡，然后是我。
Then it's Oscar back between this woman and man, but it happens within seconds. So like what kind of magic is Oscar doing? And we're like hopping all over these booths. Do you have a recollection from when we taped the episode that they were moving you around? Well, I do. I do. So in one shot, they needed to establish a reaction of everyone. And in order to do that in one sweeping pan shot, they had to stack some of us. So they moved me from my corner booth and they stuck me
128|||然后奥斯卡又回到了那个女人和男人之间，但这都是在几秒钟内发生的。所以这到底是什么样的奥斯卡魔法？我们就像在这些卡座里到处乱跳一样。你对我们拍这一集时他们把你移来移去还有记忆吗？嗯，我有的。我有的。所以在一个镜头里，他们需要确立所有人的反应。为了在一个横摇长镜头中做到这一点，他们不得不把我们中的一些人堆叠起来。所以他们把我从角落的卡座里移开，把我塞到了
in front of Oscar in his booth, and they pulled these other two people out. But in watching it, it's so funny to me because it's like Oscar keeps entertaining. He keeps having all these different people at his booth in a matter of seconds. We couldn't have physically all been up and down and back and forth like that. And then at the very end, Oscar leaves the Chili's with the original couple. Wow. That he sat with. I know guys. And who are those people?
129|||他卡座里的奥斯卡前面，然后把另外这两个人拉了出来。但看着它，我觉得太搞笑了，因为感觉就像奥斯卡一直在招待客人。他在短短几秒钟内，卡座里一直有所有这些不同的人。我们不可能在物理上那样上下跳动、来回折腾。然后到了最后，奥斯卡和最初的那对夫妇一起离开了Chili's。哇。他坐在一起的那对。我知道，伙计们。那些人到底是谁？
I don't know. We never find out. We never find out. We don't know. But anyway, it just cracked me up because I would look back there and I'd be like, oh, who's Oscar sitting with? What, what, what, what, what?
130|||我不知道。我们从来没弄清楚。我们永远不知道。我们不知道。不管怎样，这只是把我逗乐了，因为我会往那边看，然后会想，哦，奥斯卡跟谁坐在一起？什么，什么，什么，什么，什么？
But it was like a matter of seconds. Wow. Now here's the thing. If you're watching just Oscar's booth, you're missing a lot of action that you probably should be paying attention to. But I watched this episode three times prepping for this, so I watched it once just as me.
131|||但这只是几秒钟的事。哇。现在关键是，如果你只盯着奥斯卡的卡座，你会错过很多你可能应该关注的精彩动作。但我为了准备这个节目把这集看了三遍，所以我看了一遍，纯粹是以我自己的视角。
You clearly watched it once just to see what Oscar was doing. I clearly watched it once just to see what was happening in the background. I think something we should talk about is Pam and Roy fighting in the parking lot. Yes, let's talk about that. They originally said that they were not going to use the audio from this because there was no dialogue. In the script, it just said, spy shot. Pam and Roy are having a heated argument in the parking lot.
132|||你显然看了一遍，只是为了看奥斯卡在干什么。我显然看了一遍，只是为了看看背景里到底发生了什么。我想我们应该聊聊帕姆和罗伊在停车场吵架的事。是的，我们来聊聊那个。他们最初说他们不会使用这里的音频，因为没有对话。剧本里只写着，偷拍镜头。帕姆和罗伊在停车场发生激烈争吵。
Roy tugs her arm, Pam pulls away and heads back into the restaurant. Roy slams the truck door then gets in the other side. And that was it. Yeah. So David and I improvised a fight that we were having. And then they used it. Yeah.
133|||罗伊拉扯她的胳膊，帕姆甩开并朝餐厅走去。罗伊砰地关上卡车门，然后坐进另一侧。就这样。是的。所以大卫和我即兴发挥了一场我们之间的争吵。然后他们就用了。是的。
So that was so crazy. That is crazy. And I love what Pam said when she was like, you know, if you had listened, you would have known that. Of course, we don't know what you're talking about, right? But I was like, when Roy grabbed her arm, I was like, hey, hey now. I know. He gets a little physical with her sometimes with the grabbing of the arm. Someone mentioned that.
134|||这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。我喜欢帕姆说的话，当她说，你知道，如果你听了，你就会知道了。当然，我们不知道你在说什么，对吧？但当罗伊抓住她的胳膊时，我就想，嘿，嘿，等等。我知道。有时他在抓胳膊时对她确实有点动手动脚。有人提到了这一点。
Mm-hmm. And he's a big guy. He is. So you sort of really see in that moment that Pam is just fed up and she wants to stay and she wants to be with her friends. And I think she wants to be with another person. I don't know what you're talking about. Yeah.
135|||嗯哼。而且他个子很大。确实很大。所以你在那一刻真的能看出帕姆已经受够了，她想留下来，她想和她的朋友们在一起。而且我想她想和另一个人在一起。我不知道你在说什么。是的。
I think she wants to be with Jim, who she sits down at a table with. I know, and the look on his face when you come back in. He is so delighted she starts drinking his beer immediately. I know. Then she orders her own drinks and it leads us into a famous line. Who knew it would be this famous? What? Written by Mindy Kaling.
136|||我想她想和吉姆在一起，她坐到了吉姆的那张桌子旁。我知道，当你走回来时，他脸上的表情。他高兴极了，立刻开始喝他的啤酒。我知道。然后她点自己的饮料，这就把我们带到了一句著名的台词。谁能想到这会这么出名？什么？明迪·卡灵写的。
Look what I have on my note card. It's like second drink. Second drink. Yes. And Andrew Nelson asked, did you add Lib Second Drink or was it scripted? It was scripted. And a lot of people asked about what are we really drinking?
137|||看我笔记卡上写了什么。就像是第二杯。第二杯。是的。安德鲁·尼尔森问，第二杯是你们自己加的还是剧本里写的？剧本里写的。很多人问我们到底在喝什么？
Is it really alcohol? No. No, it would be so wasted. Also, it looks like something from like a Nickelodeon slime like, like a word showon slime like award show. Because do you see, if you look at Meredith's drink, it's like a neon green. Yeah, what was she drinking?
138|||真的是酒精吗？不是。不，那早就喝得烂醉如泥了。而且，它看起来就像尼克国际儿童频道的粘液秀、那种颁奖典礼上的粘液一样。因为你看，如果你看梅雷迪思的饮料，它是一种霓虹绿色。是的，她当时在喝什么？
I don't know, but I think they really wanted the drinks to pop so you could see them. And so they added a lot of food dye and things. Well, the beer is usually just non-alcoholic beer. So the beer actually tastes like beer. And you feel bloaty. Yeah, and I don't like beer, and I don't like the taste of beer, so I hate it whenever I have to drink it on camera because blah. And then other drinks like wine, it's usually
139|||我不知道，但我认为他们真的很想让饮料的颜色跳出来，这样你能看得到。所以他们加了很多食用色素之类东西。嗯，啤酒通常只是无酒精啤酒。所以啤酒实际上尝起来像啤酒。而且你会觉得肚子胀气。是的，而且我不喜欢啤酒，也不喜欢啤酒的味道，所以我讨厌任何时候在镜头前不得不喝它，因为太难喝了。然后其他饮料比如葡萄酒，通常是
watered down juice. Cranberry juice. Mm-hmm. Apple juice. Yeah. And then the other drinks are anything. Sometimes it's just water with a little food coloring in it. Or like if it is supposed to look like a bourbon or something, it could just be tea. Oh yeah. Yeah. Sometimes they'll brew you some tea and pour it over ice and then now
140|||兑水的果汁。蔓越莓汁。嗯哼。苹果汁。是的。然后其他的饮料就是随便什么。有时它只是加了一点食用色素的水。或者如果它应该看起来像波旁威士忌什么的，它可能只是茶。哦，是的。是的。有时他们会为你泡一些茶，加冰块倒进杯子里，然后现在
you have... I'm actually happy when you have that. Like if you have a Long Island iced tea and you're just drinking an iced tea. Yeah. Sam just pulled up for you guys listening a whole page on the internet of just me rolling my eyes and looking snarky. So as Angela Martin, I guess there's a lot of us snarky eye roll options out there are just snarky looks. They're not limited to the Dundee's.
141|||你就有了……当你有那个的时候我其实挺高兴的。比如如果你有一杯长岛冰茶，而你只是在喝冰茶。是的。萨姆刚刚为收听节目的你们在互联网上搜出了一整页全是我在翻白眼、看起来很刻薄的照片。所以作为安吉拉·马丁，我想我们有很多刻薄翻白眼的选项或者只是刻薄的表情。它们不仅限于邓迪奖。
Okay, Sam, take it down. I can't look at myself rolling my eyes at myself. So now we get into the tender moment where Michael is desperately trying to keep the Dundee's going and the guys at the bar start to heckle him. Yeah. And he's so wounded and Pam won't have it. Well, I think it's that moment, even there's a look that comes across Jim's face of like,
142|||好了，萨姆，把它撤了吧。我没法看着自己对自己翻白眼。现在我们进入了一个温情的时刻，迈克尔拼命地想要让邓迪奖继续下去，而酒吧里的家伙们开始起哄嘲笑他。是的。他太受伤了，而帕姆可容不得别人这么对她。嗯，我觉得就是那一刻，甚至吉姆的脸上也掠过了一个表情，仿佛在说，
ooh, like that's mean, you know? Yeah. And it's sort of that thing of like, you know, your creepy cousin that creeps everyone out, but you have to take up for them because they're your cousin. It's like that moment of like, okay, he's like family and we get to like make fun of him, but no one else can. That's right. And Pam starts chanting Dundee's and getting people to rally around him. And I love that. And this is a little bit the relationship between Pam and Michael. This
143|||哦，像那样就有点过分了，你知道吗？是的。这就有点像那种感觉，你知道，你那个让人毛骨悚然、把大家都吓退的表亲，但你还是得护着他，因为他是你表亲。就像那种感觉，好吧，他就像是家人，我们可以取笑他，但别人不行。没错。然后帕姆开始带头喊“邓迪奖”，让大家团结在他周围。我太喜欢这个了。这也是帕姆和迈克尔之间关系的一种体现。这
is the way that she shows up for him, the way he shows up for her at her art show later. Yeah. Like, in their lowest moments, they are there for one another. When Pam gives him a hug when she gets her dundee, his face is so precious. He's just like, it's like the whole night was made in that moment. Well, Pam accepting her dundee is another famous line.
144|||就是她为他挺身而出地方式，就像他后来在她的艺术展上为她挺身而出一样。是的。就像，在他们最低谷的时刻，他们彼此陪伴。当帕姆在拿到她的邓迪奖时拥抱他，他的表情太珍贵了。他简直觉得，整个夜晚就是为了那一刻而存在的。嗯，帕姆接受她的邓迪奖是另一句名言。
Yes. I feel God in this Chili's line. Yes. I feel God in this Chili's tonight. Oh, I love it. So when I rewatch this, there was this moment I wrote on my note card because when you say I'd like to thank God for this Dundee, it cuts to Jim and Jim's reaction to you thanking God for your Dundee is one of the best moments for me of the whole episode. It is just so sweet. He's just looking at you like,
145|||是的。我在这家Chili's感受到了上帝。是的。我今晚在这家Chili's感受到了上帝。哦，我太爱了。所以当我重看这一段时，我注意到并写在笔记卡上的一幕是，当你说“我要感谢上帝赐予我这个邓迪奖”时，镜头切到了吉姆，吉姆对你感谢上帝获得邓迪奖的反应对我来说是整集中最棒的时刻之一。真是太甜了。他只是看着你，仿佛在说，
oh, my sweet little drunk friend, I love you. Well, I talked to Mindy about this on the day and she had told me that Greg did not have total confidence in Pam thanking God for her Dundee, but we were gonna do it anyway. He was a little bit like, I don't totally get it. And she's like, no, you know, like whenever people win awards or they have like big sports moments,
146|||哦，我可爱的醉酒小宝贝，我爱你。嗯，我在当天和明迪谈过这个，她告诉我，格里格对帕姆感谢上帝获得邓迪奖并没有十足的信心，但我们无论如何都要拍。他有点觉得，我不太理解这个。而她说，不，你知道的，每当人们赢得奖项或者经历重大的体育时刻时，
a lot of times they thank God. And I asked her, I said, but how do I do it? Because, and she said, you do it totally sincerely. She's like, you really are like sincerely thankful and grateful for your Dundee tonight. It totally made sense to me because I felt like drunk Pam thinks this is what you do when you win an award. That's right.
147|||很多时候他们都会感谢上帝。我问她，我说，但我该怎么演呢？因为，她说，你要表现得绝对真诚。她说，你今晚真的是发自内心地真诚感谢并感激你的邓迪奖。这对我来说完全说得通，因为我觉得喝醉的帕姆认为这就是你获奖时该做的事。没错。
You take a moment, you thank God, then you scream, woohoo! Yeah. And I loved it so much. And then after this, after she gets her Dundee, Pam kisses Jim on the lips. I know. I know. Was that weird?
148|||你花点时间，感谢上帝，然后大喊一声，呜呼！是的。我太喜欢了。然后在这之后，在她拿到邓迪奖后，帕姆亲了吉姆的嘴唇。我知道。我知道。这不是很奇怪吗？
Well, this was a big fan question. Caitlin asked, do you consider this episode as Pam and Jim's first kiss? Or do you think it's casino night? I did not consider this their first kiss. I did. John did. I disagree. I consider it. You planted one on him. The intention there was that it was accidental.
149|||嗯，这是一个很大的粉丝提问。凯特琳问，你认为这一集是帕姆和吉姆的初吻吗？还是你觉得是赌场之夜？我不认为这是他们的初吻。我认为是。约翰认为是。我不同意。我认为是。你主动送上香吻了。当时的意图是那是个意外。
The intention was that Pam was going for his cheek. Uh-huh. And it was one of those moments where you, he moved his head in a way that I wasn't expecting and I'm drunk and I just followed through. That was what was in my head as Pam. So I wasn't thinking that I was intending to kiss his lips. And so Pam kind of doesn't't thinking that I was intending to kiss his lips. And so Pam kind of doesn't register it. That was me. John said that Jim, who is not drunk, was very
150|||本意是帕姆是冲着他的脸颊去的。呃-huh。那是那种你把头一偏，以一种我没料到的方式移动，而我又喝醉了，于是顺势而为的时刻。这就是帕姆脑海里想的。所以我当时没想过要去亲吻他的嘴唇。所以帕姆有点没有意识到这一点。那是我。约翰说吉姆没喝醉，他很
aware that they just kissed on the lips. And this was a whole conversation that we had off camera. I agree with him though. And I see both sides. I see as a drunk person, you just kind of hug and you're a little sloppy. Yeah. But I see for him as a sober person, this person he's in love with just kissed him. Yeah. But it was unintentional on Pam's part in her mind. I know.
151|||清楚他们刚刚亲了嘴唇。这是我们在镜头外进行的一整场对话。不过我同意他的看法。而且我能理解双方。我能理解作为一个喝醉的人，你们只是拥抱了一下，而且有点随性。是的。但我能理解对他来说，作为清醒的人，他深爱着的这个人刚刚吻了他。是的。但在帕姆的心里，那并不是故意的。我知道。
But a lot of people wrote in and said, oh my gosh, why didn't everyone in the office, why wasn't this a big gossipy moment? They know Pam's engaged and they all witnessed her kiss Jim and in my mind it was because it wasn't really a kiss. It wasn't a... Oh well in my mind everyone was talking about it at work. Trust me. Okay. Over and accounting. I tell you what, Angela Martin was sitting with Phyllis in a booth when that happened and I'm pretty sure she was like, mm-hmm, did you see the office mattress? Just to smooch someone else? Well, I have another fan question for you then. This one is from Amy.
152|||但很多人写信来问，哦天哪，为什么办公室里的其他人，为什么这没有成为一个八卦的焦点？他们知道帕姆订婚了，而且他们都目睹了她亲吻吉姆，在我的脑海里，那是因为那其实并不是一个吻。那不是一个……哦，好吧，在我的脑海里，每个人都在工作时议论纷纷。相信我。好吧。在财务部。我告诉你，当那一幕发生时，安吉拉·马丁正和菲利丝坐在一个卡座里，我敢肯定她心里在想，嗯哼，你看到办公室的公共交际花了吗？居然去亲别人？好吧，那我还有一个粉丝问题要问你。这个是艾米问的。
She said, at the end, when you drive Pam home, in my mind, Angela would be so disgusted by Pam's behavior, it seems odd that she would give her a ride. Well, let me tell you, Amy, if you watch the deleted scenes, because I did, you will see that Angela Martin has a talking head where she is the company's designated driver. And you would know that Angela Martin would take this very serious as the safety officer for Dunder Mifflin. And I have this talking head where Angela goes on to say,
她说，最后，当你开车送帕姆回家时，在我的脑海里，安吉拉会对帕姆的行为感到非常反感，她居然愿意送她一程，这似乎很奇怪。好吧，我告诉你，艾米，如果你看了删减片段，因为我看了，你会看到安吉拉·马丁有一个访谈镜头，她是公司的指定司机。而且你会知道，安吉拉·马丁作为邓德米夫林的的安全员，会把这件事看得很严肃。我有一个安吉拉接着说的访谈镜头，
and you know what, no one gives me any gas money and everyone lives all over. It's very expensive. Wow. That is gold. So she's always the martyr. She's doing her job, but no one gives her gas money and she has to drive these drunks around, but she's the designated driver. And so she has to do it. So not only did Pam probably not give her any gas money, she was very disappointed in her behavior. I'm sure.
你知道吗，没有人给我汽油钱，而且大家住得到处都是。这太贵了。哇。这简直太经典了。所以她总是扮演殉道者。她在做自己的工作，但没有人给她汽油钱，她还得开车送这些醉鬼四处奔波，但她是指定司机。所以她不得不这么做。因此，不仅帕姆可能没给她汽油钱，她对帕姆的行为也非常失望。我敢肯定。
Angela quietly judged her the whole drive and probably told her, you need to make some new life choices. Amy also wanted to know, was that really you driving? Yes, it was. At 20 minutes, two seconds in the car, you see my shoulder. Now here's the thing, they wanted me every time in the car, you got in with me every time I pulled away, and then I would back up and we'd do the scene over a few times.
一路上安吉拉都在默默地评判她，可能还对她说，你需要做出一些新的人生选择了。艾米还想知道，真的是你自己在开车吗？是的，确实是我。在车里两分钟零两秒的时候，你能看到我的肩膀。事情是这样的，每次我在车里时，他们都希望我这么做，你每次上车时我都把车开走，然后我会倒车，我们把这个场景重拍了好几次。
And I had a front row seat watching Pam and Jim have that sort of very tender but awkward moment where Pam has a question for him, but then notices the camera. I watched that whole thing over and over as you guys did it, and it was so great, you guys did such a fantastic job. And when I rewatched it, part of me was like, well, why did they have me in the car?
我有幸坐在第一排，看着帕姆和吉姆经历了那种非常温柔但又尴尬的时刻，帕姆有一个问题要问他，但随后注意到了摄像机。你们在拍的时候，我把整个过程看了又看，这太棒了，你们表现得太出色了。当我重看这一集时，我心里有一部分就在想，好吧，为什么非要把我安排在车里？
You don't see me anyway. But they didn't know. As you know, with our show, we always had an A camera and a B camera. And they would be sort of carving up the scene. And there might be this moment where they whipped around and could have seen me. So they wanted to make sure I was there just in case.
反正你也看不见我。但他们不知道。如你所知，在我们的节目中，我们总是设有一号机位和二号机位。他们会对场景进行拆解。可能会有这样一个时刻，他们猛地转过镜头，可能会看到我。所以他们想确保我在那里，以防万一。
And I was happy to be there. But also, I had... Yeah, a lot of times they would use a double for that in other shows. But in our show, we were our own doubles. That's right, because as a documentary, you really never knew where that second camera would end up landing, and you could end up on camera.
我很高兴能去。但我也……是的，很多时候在其他节目中他们会用替身。但在我们的节目中，我们自己就是自己的替身。没错，因为作为一部纪录片，你真的永远不知道第二个摄像机会落在哪儿，而且你最后可能会入镜。
I was asked, is that a cat air freshener hanging from your rear view mirror in your car? Is it? It looks like it could be a cat or a tree. Guys, I don't know. I tried to zoom in on it. Oh, I hope it's a cat. I hope it's a green.
有人问我，你车后视镜上挂着的是不是一个猫咪空气清新剂？是吗？看起来像是一只猫，也像是一棵树。伙计们，我不知道。我试着把画面放大看了看。哦，我希望那是一只猫。我希望它是一个绿色……
Let's call it a cat. I hope it's a green cat. A green cat doesn't sound right now, Angela. I know, but maybe it was a Christmas cat that I held onto. Not sure. Something we haven't talked about is the scene where Pam falls off the stool because she is so drunk. And this leads me into a fan question. Matt Shelton asked, how did you get Chili's
我们就叫它猫吧。我希望它是一只绿色的猫。安吉拉，现在听起来绿猫好像不太对劲。我知道，也许那是我一直留着的圣诞猫。不确定。有一件事我们还没聊到，那就是帕姆因为喝得太醉而从凳子上摔下来的那一幕。这让我想到了一个粉丝提问。马特·谢尔顿问，你是怎么让 Chili's
to cooperate with this idea? Well, they were on the fence and we almost weren't allowed to film there, remember? Well, here's what happened. Originally in the script, Pam vomits all over the bar. She does not fall off the stool. She is listening to Jim, she is nodding, and then she vomits.
配合这个创意的？嗯，他们当时态度犹豫，我们差点就没被允许在那里拍摄，还记得吗？好吧，事情是这样的。剧本原定的情节是，帕姆在酒吧里吐得到处都是。她并没有从凳子上摔下来。她听着吉姆说话，点着头，然后就吐了。
And we had been filming for two days. And I guess suddenly they had had Chili's permission. Chili's helped build the Chili's. And someone at Chili's read the script finally. Well, I guess- And freaked out. I read the script wasn't fully complete. You know, they hadn't done their second pass.
我们已经拍了两天了。我猜他们突然拿到了 Chili's 的拍摄许可。Chili's 帮忙建造了那个 Chili's 餐厅。然后 Chili's 的某个人终于读了剧本。嗯，我猜——并且吓坏了。我听说剧本并不是完全完整的。你知道，他们还没进行第二轮修改。
And so Chili's had not gotten all of the scenes. And so they didn't have the scene where Pam vomited and all of this happened. Well, once they read that, they shut down the production. Yes. And we thought, what? They said, no way. They were very nervous about the drinking and the drunkenness and the sort of way that that might reflect on Chili's. So Greg and Mindy started scrambling.
所以 Chili's 并没有看到所有的场景。因此他们没有帕姆呕吐以及所有这些事情发生的场景。好吧，一旦他们读到那一幕，他们就叫停了制作。是的。我们当时想，什么？他们说，没门。他们对饮酒、醉酒以及这可能会对 Chili's 造成的影响非常紧张。所以格雷格和明迪开始手忙脚乱地想对策。
And they came up with this idea that instead of vomiting, that Pam would fall off a stool. Right, and then also, I think it was Reign's idea to say, well, maybe Dwight could say, oh, she's had a seizure and not the vomiting. And then the other part of it was that we had to write in a new element, which is that Pam was going to get banned from Chili's.
他们想出了这样一个主意：与其让帕姆呕吐，不如让她从凳子上摔下来。没错，然后还有，我觉得这是雷恩提出的建议，他说，也许德怀特可以说，哦，她羊角风发作了，而不是呕吐。另一个部分是，我们必须加入一个新的元素，那就是帕姆将被 Chili's 永久禁止入内。
And the person who gives the speech in the episode was an actual Chili's manager franchise owner named John Bossert. He was not an actor. And they felt like by having an actual Chili's representative state very clearly the Chili's policy against over-serving and banning Pam for life, then they allowed us to film the rest of the episode. Yes, and also they had Pam, they had you as Pam.
在剧里发表讲话的那个人是 Chili's 的一名真正的经理兼加盟店老板，名叫约翰·博瑟特（John Bossert）。他不是演员。他们觉得，通过让一个真正的 Chili's 代表非常明确地阐述 Chili's 关于严禁过度劝酒的政策并终身禁止帕姆入内，他们才会允许我们拍摄接下来的剧集。是的，而且他们还让帕姆——让饰演帕姆的你——
A waiter never brought you more drinks. You were reaching on other people's tables. So you were doing it, not Chili's. And you know what? I think that's great. I think that it was really important to Chili's that people know that they are responsible. And a family establishment.
服务员从没给你拿过更多的酒。你是伸手去拿别人桌上的酒。所以这是你干的，而不是 Chili's。你知道吗？我觉得这太棒了。我觉得让人们知道 Chili's 是有责任心的，这对于他们来说非常重要。而且这是一个家庭式餐厅。
And a family establishment. And I love that John Bosshart, an actual Chili's like owner, got to do that talking head. I thought he did a fantastic job. He did great. His look to camera when he's like, so she is banned. Like his little look to camera was fantastic. And also that aspect of Pam being banned for life was a wonderful thing that just grew
一个家庭式餐厅。我很高兴约翰·博瑟特（John Bosshart），一个真正的 Chili's 老板，能来完成那个访谈镜头。我觉得他表现得太棒了。他表现得很出色。当他说“所以她被禁了”时，他看向摄像机的那个眼神。他看向摄像机的小眼神太棒了。而且，帕姆终身被禁赛这一情节也是一个绝妙的设定，它后来延伸出了
into many more jokes and. I know. I loved it. I loved it. Pam is like such like not a troublemaker and she's banned from like a nationwide chain. Yes. As if there is such a system that could control that. I have one card that's sort of around that area. So can I talk about it right now?
更多的笑话和……我知道。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。帕姆根本就不是那种会惹麻烦的人，但她却被一家全国连锁餐厅列入了黑名单。是的。就好像真的有这样一个系统能管得了这事儿似的。我有一张卡片差不多也是讲这块的。那我能现在聊聊吗？
Sure. Once again, Rainn Wilson finds a way to take off his shirt. Always taking off his shirt, Rainn Wilson. We get to see his beautiful white fleshy belly because somehow that's going to help save Pam. It was going to be a pillow for your head. I guess so. A lot of people asked about the falling off the stool moment. Was it scripted? Did I actually do it? It was scripted. I did actually do it. But again, like being drunk, I was very nervous about falling off the stool and making it look good. So Greg Daniels, he got on the stool and he showed me how he
当然。雷恩·威尔逊又一次找到了脱掉衬衫的机会。雷恩·威尔逊总是脱掉衬衫。我们得以看到他美丽白皙、肉乎乎的肚皮，因为不知怎么的，那能帮到帕姆。那原本是打算做你脑袋的枕头。我猜是吧。很多人问起从凳子上摔下来的那一幕。那是剧本里写好的吗？我真的摔了吗？那是剧本写的。我确实摔了。但话说回来，就像喝醉了一样，我对从凳子上摔下来并把它演好感到非常紧张。所以格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）自己坐到凳子上，向我展示了他
wanted me to fall. He said he wanted me to just keep looking at John and nodding and then slowly slip off the stool. And he's very large. He's very tall. He's tall. He's like 6'2 or something. And so he fell down. They had padding on the floor. So he and I were both falling on padding. But John Chris and Skinny, we kept pretending like we didn't understand how I should fall off the stool. On purpose to mess with Greg? So that Greg kept doing it?
想要我摔倒。他说他想让我一直看着约翰并点头，然后慢慢从凳子上滑下来。而且他非常大只。他非常高。他很高。他身高大约 6 英尺 2 英寸左右。所以他摔倒了。他们在地板上放了垫子。所以我和他都摔在了垫子上。但是约翰、克里斯和斯金尼，我们一直假装我们不明白我该怎么从凳子上摔下来。是故意捉弄格雷格吗？好让格雷格一直做那个动作？
We'd have to keep showing us. Oh my gosh. You were like, that's a moment where you were like real Jim and Pam because you were pranking Greg the way you would prank Dwight. A hundred percent. Does Greg know that? He does. And then Greg told me later, I guess John and I told that story in an interview and he confronted us. He was like, guys, you know, I really hurt my back doing that.
我们不得不一直给我们示范。哦天哪。你会觉得，那一刻你就像是真正的吉姆和帕姆，因为你捉弄格雷格的方式就像你会捉弄德怀特一样。百分之百。格雷格知道吗？他知道。后来格雷格告诉我，我想约翰和我在一次采访中讲了这个故事，他质问了我们。他当时说，伙计们，你们知道的，我做那个动作真的把背弄伤了。
No, he did not. So we were, then we felt so bad. Jenna! So we were, then we felt so bad. Juna! Oh my God, you guys. You, that was real life Jim Pam moment. It was, it was. But I love doing that.
不，他没有。所以我们当时，然后我们觉得太糟糕了。珍娜！所以我们当时，然后我们觉得太糟糕了。朱娜！哦天哪，你们。你，那是现实生活中的吉姆和帕姆时刻。是的，是的。但我喜欢那样做。
I love doing that stunt. I thought it ended up looking really good too. I was proud of it. I thought it looked fantastic. I thought that whole like part where you were nodding and then you were like, what? And he was like, what? And then you start laughing. It was so perfect.
我喜欢做那个特技。我觉得最后看起来也很棒。我为此感到自豪。我觉得它看起来棒极了。我觉得整段你一直在点头，然后你就像是，什么？然后他就像是，什么？接着你开始笑的那个部分。太完美了。
It was so perfect. This brings us to the scene with Jim in the parking lot that we were talking about a little bit earlier. A lot of people wanted to know what was Pam going to ask Jim. She wanted to bring up so many things. So I think it was- And that's what stopped her because there were so many options
太完美了。这把我们带到了我们刚才稍微聊过的一点，停车场里吉姆的那个场景。很多人想知道帕姆究竟要问吉姆什么。她想提出太多事情了。所以我认为那是——这也是阻止了她的原因，因为有太多选择了
going through her head in that moment. And I had written out in my script, all of these things that I could possibly say so that I could in that moment rifle through them, but then not pick any of them. Right. I think it's that moment where you have so much to say, and you're like, can I ask you a question? Then the floodgates would have opened. But you saw the camera and it gave you this check of like, I can't do this, not here, not now. I'm so glad that she didn't because those drunken confessional conversations, that wasn't going to lead to the right place. I'm glad the camera was there for them in that moment.
那一刻在她的脑海里闪过。我在剧本里写下了所有我可能会说的话，以便我能在那个时刻快速浏览它们，但最终什么都不选。对。我认为那是那种你有太多话要说，然后你说，我能问你一个问题吗？的时刻。接着话匣子就会打开。但你看到了摄像机，它给了你一种抑制，就像是，我不能这么做，不能在这里，不能在这个时候。我很高兴她没有这么做，因为那些酒后的真心话告白，是不会走向正确的结果的。我很高兴那一刻摄像机在那里陪伴着他们。
Because I think what Pam was going to say, what I had written in my script was something along the lines of, I love you. Well, I think the question was going to be, you know, do you think I should break up with Roy? Yeah. What do you do? You think I'm the wrong person? Yeah, those kind of leading, hoping that he'd say you are be'm the wrong person? Yeah. Those kind of leading questions.
因为我认为帕姆当时要说的话，我在剧本里写的是类似于“我爱你”这样的话。嗯，我认为那个问题会是，你知道的，你觉得我应该和罗伊分手吗？是的。你觉得呢？你觉得我是错的人吗？是的，那种带有引导性的问题，希望他说……
Hoping that he'd say, you are, be with me. Yes, exactly. Yes. So here's the crazy thing. We mentioned earlier that our second season only had six episodes picked up, that this was the third episode that we shot, and we didn't know this was going to be the premiere of season two when we shot it. In fact, one of the ideas was that if we got canceled,
希望他说，你是，和我在一起。是的，完全正确。是的。所以，这里有个疯狂的事情。我们之前提到过，我们的第二季只预定了六集，这是我们拍摄的第三集，而且我们在拍摄时并不知道这将是第二季的首播集。事实上，当时的构想之一是，如果我们被砍了，
it would be the season finale. And so I said to Greg, I think just in case we get canceled, and this is the season finale, I think we should film an alternate ending to this scene in the parking lot where Pam does tell Jim how she feels and they kiss for real. Not the Chili's kiss, but the real kiss just so that we could air it and we don't leave people hanging. And Greg said, no. He said no. If they want to see what happens with Jim and Pam, they're just gonna have to order more episodes.
它就会成为季终集。所以我对格雷格说，以防万一我们被砍了，而且这成了季终集，我认为我们应该为停车场这个场景拍摄一个备用结局，在那个结局里帕姆真的告诉了吉姆她的感受，他们真的接吻了。不是奇利餐厅的那个吻，而是真正的吻，这样我们就可以播出了，而不会把观众晾在那里。格雷格说，不。他说不。如果他们想看吉姆和帕姆会有什么结果，他们就得去争取更多的剧集。
I don't want to give them a choice. There you go. He was very protective of Jim and Pam, too. He was. And what went out in the world about that relationship. But that shows you how much we thought we were going to be canceled all the time. All the time.
我不想给他们选择的余地。就是这样。他对吉姆和帕姆也非常保护。他是的。而且对于那种关系在世人面前呈现出的样子也是如此。但这就向你展示了我们当时有多么觉得我们随时会被砍掉。随时随地。
I was pitching ideas for how to wrap up the whole series just in case. If you think that a normal show gets, well, at that time, network TV, you would get 22 episodes and we got six. It doesn't make you feel like anyone's really confident about what you're doing. Like we didn't think NBC was like,
我一直在推销各种如何给整个剧集收尾的点子，以防万一。如果你认为一部普通的剧集会获得——好吧，在那个时候的电视网节目，你会得到 22 集，而我们只得到了 6 集。这不会让你觉得任何人对你在做的事真的很有信心。就像我们不觉得 NBC 会觉得，
oh, we got a winner here. I have some deleted scenes cards. Oh, tell them. Well, one of the ones I really loved is that Toby does a talking head where he says he's never won a Dundee. Oh, yeah. Michael refuses to give Toby a Dundee. He just leaves them out every year. And now everyone in the office gets a Dundee but Toby. And I think, and Toby's like, I'm okay with that.
哦，我们这里出了个赢家。我有一些被删减场景的卡片。哦，快告诉大家。嗯，我真的很喜欢的一个是托比做了一段面对镜头的独白，他说他从来没赢得过邓迪奖。哦，对。迈克尔拒绝给托比颁发邓迪奖。他每年都把他晾在一边。现在办公室里的每个人都得到了邓迪奖，只有托比没有。而且我认为，托比却说，我对此觉得还好。
I thought that was really funny. And then there's a great Dwight Angela scene at the copier where Dwight is really trying to force Angela to tell him what was written on the bathroom wall. And I'm like, I don't repeat those kind of things. It's inappropriate. I don't say those words out loud. And then Dwight's like, does it have anything to do with his butt or his wiener? And I just walk off in a huff. But it's the very first time I feel like Dwight and I have some little clandestine conversation just between the two of us. Oh That's a good one. Yeah Pam does confess that she wrote it on the wall She does about Michael, but we don't find out what it was which I love too I love what she's like. I feel bad about what I wrote and he's like, no, you don't
我觉得那真的很好笑。然后复印机旁有一个精彩的德怀特和安吉拉的场景，德怀特真的在强迫安吉拉告诉他洗手间墙上写了什么。而我就像是，我才不重复那种话呢。这很不恰当。我不会大声说出那些字眼。然后德怀特就像是，这跟他的屁股或者他的老二有关系吗？然后我就气冲冲地走开了。但这是我觉得我和德怀特第一次有一些只属于我们两个人的秘密谈话。哦，那真是一个好桥段。对，帕姆确实承认了那是她写在墙上的，她是关于迈克尔写的，但我们并没有发现具体写的是什么，我也很喜欢这一点。我喜欢她那种感觉，她说：我对我写的东西感到很糟糕，而他却说：不，你才不觉得糟糕呢。
People wanted to know did we all get to keep our Dundee's? Yes, we did. Yes, we did We all have them. I have two. I have two as well. I have longest engagement and widest sneakers. They gave me the longest engagement that you see me win in earlier years. I have the tight ass award.
人们想知道我们是不是都留下了各自的邓迪奖？是的，我们留下了。是的，我们都留下了。我们每个人都有。我有两个。我也有两个。我有“最长订婚奖”和“最宽运动鞋奖”。他们给了我你在前几季中看到我赢得的“最长订婚奖”。我有“傲慢混蛋奖”。
And then from years later, which we'll get to, I have the she's kind of a bitch. I think Pam doesn't get a Dundee the second time around. I don't think so. There weren't as many that round. I have a final fan question. This is something for us to discuss, Angela. This is from Samantha.
然后是几年后的奖项，我们稍后会讲到，我得到了“她有点像个碧池”奖。我想帕姆在第二轮中没有得到邓迪奖。我想是的。那一轮没有那么多奖项。我有一个最后的粉丝问题。这是我们要讨论的事情，安吉拉。这是萨曼莎提出的。
Okay. She says, the last two times I have watched this episode, which is one of my top five favorite episodes, we have immediately been hit by a tornado. What? Within 10 minutes of the line, I feel God in this Chili's tonight. Samantha, first of all, where do you live?
好的。她说，最近两次我看这一集时——这一集是我最喜欢的五集之一——我们立刻就遭遇了龙卷风袭击。什么？距离那句台词“我今晚在这家奇利餐厅感受到了上帝”不到 10 分钟。萨曼莎，首先，你住在哪里？
Do you think I'm jinxed, or is it just bad luck? Should Samantha ever watch this episode again? I would say, do you live in Tornado Alley? Do you live in, like, Kansas, North Texas, Oklahoma? Like, where do you live? Right. And perhaps the next time you watch it, watch it in the storm cellar?
你觉得你被霉运缠身了，还是只是运气不好？萨曼莎以后还应该看这一集吗？我想说，你住在龙卷风走廊吗？你是不是住在堪萨斯州、德克萨斯州北部、俄克拉荷马州之类的敌方？你到底住哪儿？对。也许你下次看的时候，在风暴地窖里看？
Or maybe hit pause right before that line. Check the weather. Skip it, just skip ahead and watch the end. And come back. That is a crazy coincidence. That is crazy. That was the craziest fan question we got. I had to include it because I found it so charming
或者在那句台词前按暂停？查看天气。跳过它，直接跳过并观看结尾。然后回来。这真是个疯狂的巧合。太疯狂了。这是我们收到的最疯狂的粉丝问题。我必须把它包括进来，因为我发现它太迷人了
and I was a little worried about Samantha. That was it. That's the Dundee! That is the Dundees! And next week we will be talking about sexual harassment. The episode sexual harassment. Correct. We will be talking about the episode sexual harassment.
而且我有点为萨曼莎担心。就是这样。这就是邓迪奖！这就是邓迪奖！下周我们将讨论性骚扰。性骚扰那一集。没错。我们将讨论性骚扰那一集。
Alright you guys see you then. Thanks for tuning in. Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer
好了，各位，回头见。谢谢收听。谢谢。感谢收听 Office Ladies 的第二杯饮品。本集最初是与 Earwulf 合作创作的。Office Ladies 是 Odyssey 的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人
is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey 的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。Office Ladies 的混音和母带制作由克里斯·巴西尔完成。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。